mais mes chers collègues je suis très
heureux d'accueillir monsieur jean
pierre farandou président directeur
général de sncf
il y a tout juste un an monsieur le
président directeur général nous
confirmions dans vos fonctions et
l'audition d'aujourd'hui permettra donc
de faire un bilan de vos deux premières
années à la tête du groupe sncf l'an
dernier vous nous indiquer que si
2020 a été une année de révélations 2021
sera une année d'accélération
nous arrivons au terme de cette année
2021 et je souhaitais avant toute chose
vous demander si l'accélération que vous
évoquiez s'est effectivement produite
d'après vous quelles sont les grandes
perspectives et les principaux objectifs
qui attendent le groupe pour 2022 je
vous pose cette question car le groupe
sncf c'est-à-dire chacune 2 et de ses
entités qui le composent je pense sncf
voyageurs à keolis sncf réseau sa
filiale gares et connexions et c est
confrontée à d'importantes mutations et
à des défis sans précédent en ce qui
concerne le transport de voyageurs
d'abord une double mutation d'ampleur
est à l'oeuvre avec
d'une part une diminution importante des
trafics sous l'effet de la crise
sanitaire et des changements des
comportements des usagers télétravail
usage de la voiture etc et d'autre part
l'ouverture à la concurrence qui devient
une réalité
puisque trenitalia
fera circuler des trains grande vitesse
sur le paris-lyon à compter du 18
décembre prochain et que plusieurs
régions se sont engagés dans une telle
démarche pour ce qui est des services
conventionnés pourriez vous revenir sur
ces deux évolutions marquantes et en
particulier sur l'impact à date de la
crise sanitaire sur le groupe et sur
l'éventuelle remise en question de ce
modèle économique et financier
alors que le projet de loi de finances
pour 2022 prévoit la suppression de la
taxe sur le résultat des entreprises
ferroviaires et de la contribution de
solidarité territoriale
enfin peut-être pourriez-vous nous
détailler les évolutions de la politique
commerciale et tarifaire
que vous envisagez dans ce contexte et
les grands axes de votre stratégie en
matière de qualité de service
la dernière comparaison établie par
l'autorité de la qualité de service dans
les transports fait état d'une situation
qui peut encore être amélioré malgré les
progrès réalisés
je souhaitais également vous interrogez
monsieur le président sur le climat
social au sein du groupe puisque nous
avons très récemment appris que
plusieurs syndicats ont déposé un
préavis de grève à la sncf pour ce
week-end de départ en vacances et pour
les fêtes de fin d'année donc contexte
de négociation des accords de branche où
en sont les discussions
par ailleurs les français pourront-ils
eux profiter pleinement des fêtes en
ayant les moyens de circuler dans de
bonnes conditions
pour ce qui est du gestionnaire
d'infrastructure sncf réseau joue un
rôle absolument stratégique et ses
moyens ont été considérablement
augmentés par le biais du plan de
relance puisque 4 7 milliards d'euros
lui ont été alloués pour le financement
d'investissements en matière
d'infrastructures ferroviaires pour
autant la commission suivant l'avis du
rapporteur philippe tabarot estimé que
cette enveloppe étalé sur trois ans
demeurait malgré tout insuffisantes pour
rattraper le retard de la france dans
l'entretien de son réseau et sa
modernisation et pour véritablement
donné au ferroviaire les moyens de nos
ambitions en matière de report modal et
de réduction des émissions liées au
secteur des transports
partagez vous ce constat par ailleurs
pourriez vous détailler les grands
projets d'infrastructure envisagée dans
les prochaines années pour atteindre ces
objectifs
et les moyens déployés en faveur des
petites lignes ferroviaires sujet qui
intéresse notre commission au premier
plan d'une part et sur ce sujet la ligne
saint dié epinal a d'ailleurs été très
récemment réouverte et pour la
désaturation des grands noeuds
ferroviaires d'autre part par ailleurs
l'actualisation du contrat de
performance entre cncf réseau et l'état
devrait nous être transmis sous peu à
l'issue des différentes conduites
consultation prévue par la loi avec
environ deux ans de retard nous aurons
sans doute l'occasion d'entendre le
présent directeur général de sncf réseau
sur ce document pourriez-vous nous en
nous en dira nous dire où en sont les
négociations du contrat entre l'état et
gares connexions
enfin monsieur plaisir pourriez vous
évoquer la situation de fret sncf et les
perspectives de développement du fret
ferroviaire
notre commission est particulièrement
attentive à ce sujet ainsi qu'en
témoignent les travaux de la mission
d'information sur le transport de
marchandises face aux impératifs
environnementaux
dans les conclusions rendues en mai
dernier souligne à la fois la nécessité
de la montée en puissance du fret
ferroviaire mais aussi les nombreux
obstacles à lever pour concrétiser nos
objectifs je présente je ne serai pas
pions et je vous laisse à présent la
parole
avant de donner à mes collègues la
parole pour des questions qui ne
manqueront pas de vous poser merci
monsieur le président donc votre
introduction est très vaste et peut-être
y reste un peu plus vite pour laisser la
place aux questions bien sûr et on verra
dans les questions comment répondre à
tous les points que vous avez ok vous
êtes pas trompés vous avez cité tous les
grands enjeux du ferroviaire ils sont
nombreux on a pu le voir et chacun
demande un peu de développement et je le
ferai certainement à l'occasion des
questions des sénateurs dans cette
commission
je préparais un petit discours
introductif pour lancer un peu le débat
donc je vous salue bien sûr monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je suis honoré d'être présent
avec vous c'est une on est en train de
constituer une petite tradition mais
elle est bonne c'est que je viens de
plancher tous les ans devant devant les
commission ad-hoc donc celle là le
développement durable aménagement du
territoire ça me paraît une très bonne
chose je les fais l'assemblée nationale
je le fais bien volontiers au sénat je
crois qu'en tant qu'entreprise quand
patron de l'entreprise publique c'est
une occasion de faire le point de vous
écouter et de m'exprimer et ça ça vous
aidera à ça aidera chacun à bien prendre
à moi d'entendre vos remontées et et
pour vous d'écouter le point de la
situation que je peux faire
c'est vrai que depuis mon arrivée il ya
deux ans déjà deux ans ça passe vite un
peu plus de deux ans c'était début
novembre
j'ai été confronté à une succession de
crises donc j'ai pas vraiment traversé
une période enfin nominal j'allais dire
donc crise sociale très vite avec la
réforme des retraites et le christ la
crise sociale nationale qui est qui qui
a pu intervenir et on a eu je crois
quelques jours de répit on a démarré le
coc vide qui a été très sévère pour la
sncf puisque très rapidement pour
raisons sanitaires on a dû quasiment
arrêté les circulations des trains de
longues distances voilà on n'avait pas
vu ça depuis très longtemps de voeux
depuis voit donc depuis la première fois
depuis 40 ans le trafic tgv s'est arrêté
a ralenti avec des conséquences
financières importantes des conséquences
sociales et on en est pas sorti alors
cessé - moins grave que ça ne l'était en
mars dernier mais on a encore des
difficultés à déployer nos services je
pense notamment nos services
internationaux qui sont à chaque fois
contrarié par les mesures sanitaires
différentes entre la grande bretagne et
la france entre la belgique ou les
pays-bas et la france voilà donc c'est
très compliqué pour nous pour nos
services eurostar et thalys
je reviendrai sur le social parce que je
traiterai à la fin parce qu'on appelait
à la q pour le coup c'est une actu
chaude j'avais dire c'est qu'elle veut
dire donc je ferai un petit un petit
développement rapide à la fin de mon
propos introductif sûr mais ça de côté
si j'ose dire durant la crise sanitaire
en tout cas je pense que les français et
la représentation nationale vous avez pu
le constater le groupe sncf et les
cheminots ont été au rendez vous à la
fois nous avons appliqué avec beaucoup
de rigueur des consignes sanitaires du
gouvernement pour la pour la sécurité
sanitaire de nos voyageurs et de notre
personnel d'ailleurs on a et ça il faut
le dire on a et en année quelque part
pierre on a vu quasiment zéro cluster
dans les transports ou du dans nos
personnels à travers cette crise là donc
ça veut dire que les mesures prises ont
été efficaces c'était important ce qui
fait que les cheminots ont été au rendez
vous à la fois des confidents mais aussi
d'aider confinement on a oublié on a
relancé tout le trafic à l'été 2020 ou
quasiment on a à nouveau relancée trafic
à l'été 2000 21 l'effet de 2020 et c'est
pour ça que l'effet 2021 vous êtes en
capacité de le faire aussi on a
introduit le pass a littéralement du
gouvernement en plein été ce n'était pas
simple à organiser on l'a fait et c'est
efficace on a fait des tgv sanité on
s'en souvient je pense que la sncf les
cheminots ont joué leur rôle à la
hauteur des enjeux pour le pays je crois
que l'entreprise publique a démontré
qu'on pouvait compter sur elle
dire aussi que je vous remercie je
remercie le gouvernement je remercie le
parlement nous avaient soutenus sur
quelques dossiers importants je pense en
particulier à la suppression dans la loi
de finances de taxes qui pesait sur les
tgv pour financer les trains écueils du
territoire dont c'est l'attrait fait la
cst pour les spécialistes ces taxes mais
n'avait plus lieu d'être elle datait
d'une dizaine d'années elles n'étaient
plus compatibles avec l'ouverture à la
concurrence il faut enlever n'est
pénalisé le tgv le gouvernement a
accepté de les retirer et le parlement a
voté la suppression de cet axe où je
vous en remercie on a pu démontrer notre
solidité c'est aussi peut-être le moment
d'un bilan rapide de la réforme en tout
cas j'y reviendrai cette réforme 2018
voulue par le par le par les écuries
fait est votée par le parlement elle
crée la nouvelle sncf elle elle est
fondamentale dans notre dans notre
statut juridique de société anonyme ce
qui est quand même très différent par
rapport à des épis cas là la rigueur
financière et plus et accru le contrôle
de la dette et renforcer donc les
impératifs financiers ccc voulu
d'ailleurs assez l'objectif du
législateur se sont considérablement
accrues je rappelle les maquereaux
objectif d' équilibre c'est l'année
prochaine équilibre global du groupe
sncf donc ce qu'on appelle les
cash-flows à 0,1 il était très négatif
au début de la réforme était à moins 2
milliards donc voilà donc c'est
important et on a comme ça des objectifs
qui s'égrènent dans le temps et nous
sommes je pense en capacité de le faire
si on n'a pas à nouveau et sur des
catastrophes sanitaires qui nous
conduirait à nouveau à ralentir le nôtre
trafic grande distance
/
vous dire aussi que j'ai essayé de
mettre l'accent sur les territoires et
on partait noise tout près c'est simple
c'était beaucoup trop centralisée
c'était avaient coupé un peu les ponts
avec les forces vives des territoires
les collectivités les régions bien sûr
et on sait à quel point c'est
fondamental mais aussi les métropoles
mais aussi des territoires plus ruraux
je pense qu'elle la sncf doit trouver
cette capacité à écouter les territoires
travailleurs et les territoires mais sur
dans les zones dans les zones rurales on
sera souvent avec la région puisqu'on va
parler de tv on va parler des choses
comme ça donc ce sera toujours bien sûr
avec la région qui est là qui est là qui
est la patronne j'allais dire là
l'autorité organisatrice de la mobilité
sur sur son territoire la qualité de
service j'ai une conscience claire de ce
sujet avec suis moi-même cheminots de
longue date donc je connais bien
l'exploitation ferroviaire je sais aussi
de mon expérience que tout part de là je
veux dire si la cie la qualité de
service est au rendez vous tout va bien
la relation avec des élus se passe bien
la relation est d'usagé se passe bien
nos dossiers sont bien vus voilà c'est
le cercle vertueux al'inverse al'inverse
qu'encore la qualité de service se
dégrade là c'est un cercle vicieux qui
se met en place les gens n'ont plus
confiance dans le train ils l'expriment
les élus font leur travail de renvoyer
ces messages pas toujours agréables à
l'essai mais le mérite et à partir de là
on a une situation qui est plus
compliqué bon nous nous alors c'est une
situation un peu particulière on a les
statistiques pour nous mais le ressenti
pas toujours voilà les statistiques
moyennes mais les moyens ne veulent rien
dire on le sait bien mais bon pour
autant on fait les calculs les moyens
s'améliore on peut donc partout tgv ter
transilien on a deux points
d'amélioration donc c'est assez
satisfaisant donc ça c'est la vision
moyenne mais la vision locale là il ya
des contrastes on sait qu'on a certains
territoires alors c'est curieux parce
que quand j'étais plus jeune cheminot
c'était dans le sud qu'on avait des
problèmes et le nord marché très bien
lacées inverse n'est ce pas philippe le
sud va bien et feeling n'est pas
étranger d'ailleurs ici il s'est employé
la bretagne elle va toujours bien ça ça
n'a pas changé mais c'est le nord
maintenant les régions plus au nord et
le nord la normandie
même ligne grand test on a des
difficultés donc on a des difficultés il
faut l'admettre il faut le reconnaître
et je le reconnais je reconnais qu'il
est normal que les usagers ne soient pas
satisfaits à partir de là la balle est
dans notre camp pour voir comment on
peut créer les conditions de retour à un
niveau de
qualité de service suffisant on s'y
emploie j'y reviendrai je pense dans vos
questions là dessus
vous dire que vous sentez qu'on a de
l'énergie on n'en manque pas
heureusement parce qu'il en faut pour
animer une entreprise aussi vaste et
aussi complexe on a quatre axes avons
canali cette action vous êtes élargie
pour la canaliser quand même faut pas
être tous tous azimuts on a quatre axes
sur laquelle on fait porter entre
accents l'humain d'un petit paradoxe j'y
reviendrai quand on voit le social mais
on lâche pas la faire c'est une histoire
de transformation la loi et nous nous
demandons nous transformer pour nous
adapter à la concurrence en particulier
cette transformation elle est forte elle
vient percuter les cheminots donc on a
forcément un sujet de
compréhension de positionnement
d'accompagnement de cette transition
forte bon voilà donc l'humain est
absolument clé
mais il est pas facile les territoires
j'en ai parlé c'est indispensable
innovation lab est sûre si on tgv on
n'en fera pas tous les ans mais may à
l'innovation dans nos métiers il ya
l'innovation dans nos services le
digital est souvent des leviers de cette
innovation j'étais absolument qu'on soit
innovant il faut trouver il faut
inventer des solutions je pense aux très
léger dans les territoires - - danse etc
il ya beaucoup d'innovations matériel
roulant méthode méthodes industrielles
par exemple comment on fait en sorte que
dans quelques années n'y ait plus de
pannes techniques et je pense que c'est
possible par la maintenance prédictive
puisqu'on a des capteurs partout on peut
repérer les organes qui commence à
souffrir que ce soit sur le matériel
roulant ou sur l'infrastructure et donc
intervenir avant avant que ça tombe en
panne et ça ça permettra une
amélioration de la régularité très
importante donc il faut pas lâcher la
technologie les cheveux ingénieur au
départ quand même et je pense que la
technologie le progrès technique peut
nous amener des marges de progression
dans la qualité de service
l'environnement et j'aurais pu commencer
par là me fait dire le discours mais
c'est vrai c'est un peu la mère de
toutes les batailles au fond au font
prendre conscience que le ferroviaire
est certainement une des solutions je
veux pas dire la solution ce serait
présomptueux mais certainement la grande
solution de mobilité massive à la fois
pour les voyageurs et pour les
marchandises voilà si vraiment on veut
s'attaquer pour de vrai à la réduction
des gaz à effet de serre il faut
s'attaquer au secteur des transports qui
est le celui qui aimait le plus 30% et
si on ouvre la boîte des transports
c'est assez simple ce qu'il faut faire
il faut il faut faire du report modal
démo de polluants vers les modes peu
polluant pas polluants comme le train
électrique voilà donc c'est assez clair
je développe pas mais je pense que la
ligne tout le monde a compris après
derrière bien sûr tout est dans l'art
d'exécution bien évidemment
régénérer le réseau le réseau là aussi
c'est une vérité et ferroviaires je
l'avais dit dès ma première intervention
et je sais que c'est maintenant bien
perçue par vous il n'y a pas de chemin
de fer sans bon réseau le réseau c'est
la base de tout ça c'est ingrat sassi
n'augure pas ça se voit pas
mais voilà si les rails sont pas de
qualité il n'y a pas de bons services
ferroviaires voilà parce que quand les
rails sont pas fiables on est obligé il
ya des pannes les pannes pénalise la
régularité on est obligé de réduire la
vitesse est moins attractive là encore
les cercles vicieux se mette en place le
réseau c'est fondamental voilà donc je
l'aï su je suis un militant de là deux
choses ce qu'on appelle la régénération
la régénération c'est un mot techno qui
veut dire on remplace les vieux rails
par des rails neufs c'est un vrai sujet
un des rêves yunnan à l'âge moyen du
réseau français je le rappelle ses 33
ans quand le réseau allemand le réseau
sur le réseau allemand est à 17 le
réseau suisse et à 15 ans le mon
collègue suisse j'aime bien cette petite
anecdote je l'envié un peu au delà des
montagnes c'est que il change tout
sérail de tout son réseau en 30 ans donc
il ya pas un rail qui a plus de 30 ans
et la moyenne et donc à 15,6 ont fait
court voilà nous nous la moyenne est à
33 avec des écarts types très important
j'ai des rails quand 60 ans 70 ans et je
pourrais dire même plus voilà donc voila
voila la situation du réseau ferroviaire
français il faut absolument avoir la
détermination de reno de régénérer les
composants physiques mais ça ne suffit
et ça c'est à peu près calais par le
contrat père j'y reviendrai voilà il ya
une bande considérer que le contrat de
performance nous donne les moyens aux
fins nous nous met en situation de
pouvoir financer nous mêmes d'ailleurs
au passage la régénération du rail
français bon par contre la modernisation
et ça vous l'avez évoqué cher président
à travers les ccr et commande
centralisée du réseau sayah quasiment
rien donc on a un autre défi qui est que
notre réseau ne perdent pas de son
attractivité de perdre pad on est on est
en train de se décaler par rapport au
meilleur réseau européen l'allemand le
suisse le belge l'hollandais etc voire
même l'italien on est en train petit à
petit de perdre notre rang et si on fait
pas attention dans dix ans dans 20 ans
on verra que notre réseau est loin
d'être aux standards modernes réseau
ferroviaire performant c'est un enjeu
bien sûr de capacité de fiabilité et si
on veut comme moi j'espère comme la
plupart d'entre vous augmenter le volume
transporté par le par le faire à la fois
aux voyageurs et marchandises il faut
modérer leur ai donc sinon on n'y
arrivera pas on sera pris par un goulet
d'étranglement physique qui empêchera de
fait la progression des volumes
transportés par le ferroviaire dont
c'est un enjeu absolument déterminant ce
qui pose le sujet du financement de tout
ça bien évidemment parce qu'on parle en
milliards
voir une dizaine de milliards bon le
financement c'est pas simple mais
surtout le monde sait que c'est pas
simple moi je pense que ça ressort
beaucoup d'un certain courage politique
de certains volontarisme politique je
pourrais donner quelques exemples j'ai
parlé des suisses plus près de nous on
associer du grand paris
l'exécutif et le législatif ancrer les
moyens de financer 35 milliards d'euros
pour créer 100 km de métro automatique
en région parisienne pourquoi on ferait
pas la même chose pour le rail français
voilà c'est pas impossible
sans parler aussi de sujets européens où
je sais pas si vous le savez mais le le
transport des poids lourds des poids
lourds de marchandises qui sillonnent
l'europe je pense qu'on a tous été
confrontés à ces camions qui traversent
l'europe ces entreprises là ne sont pas
soumises au système de taxe carbone ça
paraît curieux elles ne sont pas
soumises si on avait une vision de
courage politique ça n'avait le courage
politique de les y soumettre il faut
savoir que ça pourrait rapporter jusqu'à
100 milliards d'euros par an au niveau
européen mais si on dit que la france
est un gros 10% pour faire simple dans
les calculs ça fait 10 milliards pour la
france donc on voit que mais tout ça
passe bien évidemment par
d'une certaine détermination politique
qui n'est pas faux facile je le
reconnais mais en tout cas c'est
possible je le pense profondément la
concurrence m'avait interpellé mais ça y
est c'est parti la france est un des
derniers pays à avoir ouvert la
concurrence
c'est normal que nous le fassions moi je
n'ai pas d'états d'âme la sucer la
droite européenne aux lois françaises
quasiment tous les autres pays européens
l'ont fait donc nous on a un peu retardé
l'échéance mais ça mais ça va vite
maintenant la région provence alpes côte
d'azur a mis en oeuvre la possibilité
qui lui était donnée de mettre en
concurrence de l'eau la sncf en a gagné
on a perdu un autre c'est la vie dès que
les monopoles sourd on ne peut que
perdre assez mécanique le tout c'est que
on va essayer de faire le moins possible
mais tous derrière moi avec ma position
de patron du système ferroviaire
français
bienvenue aux nouveaux opérateurs j'ai
pas d'état d'âme avec les nouveaux
opérateurs je dois d'ailleurs veillé à
ce qu'il soit accueilli avec la plus
grande équité ils doivent en accès au
réseau accès aux gares exactement la
même manière que la sncf transporteur a
accès à ces facilités essentielles donc
j'ai fait très attention et on y arrive
puisque d'ailleurs on le voit les les
italiens ce coup ci traîne italien va
effectivement démarré les services de
train à grande vitesse entre milan turin
lyon et paris c'est lyon paris qui est
visé c'est pas hasard céline la plus
rentable c'est un grand classique les
concurrents arrivent là où ça rapporte
et on les verra beaucoup moins dans les
lignes qui rapportent pas ou qui perd de
l'argent mais ça on en parlera aussi
c'est peut-être un angle mort de la
réforme sur la concurrence et la
péréquation qui rompu par la concurrence
qu'est ce que ça veut dire sur les
lignes qui sont pas rentables bien
petits sujets qu'il faudra peut-être que
nous discutions je terminerai par le
côté industriel de du ferroviaire je
pense qu'il faut en avoir cette
perception je considère d'ailleurs
j'étais avec eux j'étais avec la
fédération des industries ferroviaires
hier avec son président louis a
bien connu de vous tous et sénateurs
c'est une filière industrielle le
ferroviaire vire d'excellence qui plus
est un c'est une fille redéfinir des
filières d'excellence
ya la sncf quelqu'un d'un opérateur
d'euros mondiale quand même et je ne
nous considère aussi comme des
industriels dans la maintenance du
matériel par la pose des voies ferrées
on est quand même aussi on a des
activités très industrielle avec avec
des machines avec des process on est
vraiment industriels mais bien sûr les
alstom l'ailé tout là toute la sous
traitance ferroviaire le btp le btp qui
créent les lignes alors ça fait beaucoup
d'emplois quand on construit des
nouvelles ça fait beaucoup d'emplois qui
ruisselle dans toute l'économie et
honnêtement de vous à moi
de l'emploi français souvent pas
seulement ça peut être européen mais
dans les faits on voit bien que c'est
souvent les entreprises françaises qui
profite finalement des programmes
industriels que l'on peut mettre en
avant sur le ferroviaire je le dis parce
que c'est une c'est un endroit où on est
on est dans les tous premiers attention
à pas s'endormir sur nos lauriers c'est
pour ça aussi je pense que le des
projets de développement que je porte
accompagneront la puissance de la
filière parce que je vois nos amis
allemands et des notamment la nouvelle
coalition qui vient de prendre le
pouvoir en allemagne mettre beaucoup
d'argent dans le ferroviaire beaucoup
d'argent et on peut être sûr que
l'industrie allemande et je suis
derrière voilà donc je pense soyons
vigilants aussi à cet aspect industriel
je voulais le souligner parce qu'il
n'est pas connu souvent il n'est pas
cité mais je pense qu'on doit tous avoir
en tête on soutient nos entreprises au
soutien de l'emploi sur notre territoire
sans par la souveraineté qui peut y
avoir avec
voilà donc vous l'avez compris j'ai de
l'ambition mais je suis aussi conscient
des difficultés j'ai pas répondu par le
menu toutes les thématiques soulevées
par le président mais bien évidemment je
suppose que vous allez reprendre ce qui
me permettra de pouvoir préciser les les
questions que j'ai pu à borotou cas les
réponses que j'ai pu aborder lors de mon
de mon introduction merci beaucoup merci
messieurs présents donc je vais donner
la parole à un philippe tabarot puis un
olivier jacquin et après j'ai dix-sept
ou dix-huit demandes de dons qu'on
essaiera de respecter un temps oui je
t'ai vu je t'ai vu on essaiera de
respecter un temps de deux minutes à 2
minutes 30 moi ça me dérange pas si on
reste jusqu'à 14h 15h s'impose un
problème et je voudrais pas en avoir
leurs proches
je voudrais demander aux collègues de
m'excuser d'être un peu long et réduire
au maximum ça va c'est bon d'accord les
rapportant c'est sherbrooke à la serva
non non j'en profite pas j'en profite
président farandou on va pas parler du
dialogue du dialogue social j'aurai
l'occasion de poser une question au
gouvernement cet après midi voilà tout
simplement vous dire que dans cette
période on compatit à la fois avec les
usagers avec eux et avec vous qui fait
tout pour redresser la sncf et qui je le
sais un dialogue social permanent donc
je trouve assez injuste qui se passe en
ce moment mais j'aurai l'occasion de
m'exprimer cet après midi devant mes
collègues et le gouvernement moi je
souhaite vous interroger sur trois
points qui concernent à la fois les
taxes qui pèsent sur le ferroviaire sur
la compétitivité du ferroviaire et ce
qui en découle notamment au niveau des
investissements vous avez parlé des
questions financières aidées et des
taxes et notamment la suppression de la
cst de la trêve merci d'avoir rappelé la
part importante avec mes collègues que
nous avons pris sur cette question et
sur le positionnement qui a été le note
mais ça implique d'autres questions je
pense qu olivier jacquin vous en parlera
dans un instant moi j'aimerais votre
position sur la tva à 5,5 ça a été une
vraie question si on l'a voté plusieurs
fois dans cette dans cette assemblée
et à chaque fois mon ami alors collègues
rapporteur général du budget us on me
dit et nous dit
voilà il c'est pas une volonté de la
sncf de voir là la tva
redevenir un produit de première
nécessité
nous c'est c'est pas notre position
majoritaire ici nous croyons que ce mode
de transport
peut permettre d'atteindre des objectifs
de décarbonation et que la question de
la tvh air est quand même une vraie
question notamment en prod sur le coût
du billet pour favoriser un report modal
tellement souhaitée par tous
la deuxième question sur l'ouverture à
la concurrence
deux aspects alors à la fois là la
question et vous l'avez abordé de
l'indépendance des scènes cf réseau
maintenant avec
les deux années de recul que vous avez à
ce que vous pensez encore que d'avoir
toujours le gestionnaire
d'infrastructure dans le même groupe que
l'opérateur historique
peut encourager
de vives et difficiles discussions avec
les nouveaux opérateurs alternatifs peut
leur permettre
l'exemple de deux des italiens le monde
mais pour autant est-ce que vous pouvez
maintenir cette intégration verticale en
accordant des sillons qui reviennent aux
opérateurs alternatifs
autre question de la concurrence entre
les modes de transport ça c'est un vrai
sujet qu'on a eues ici également au
moment de climat et résilience quand il
ya eu la question de la suppression de
ces lignes
d'avion et notamment entre bordeaux et
paris nous ce qu'on s'est dit
majoritairement ici également que le
problème le problème n'était pas là la
concurrence qu'on considérait que
c'était pas une vraie concurrence parce
que il y avait des trajets en avion sur
cette distance en fin ou sur cette ligne
qui étaient moins chers en avion qu
emprunte donc que c'était un très
mauvais message qui était qui étaient
envoyés et donc on a déposé un
amendement qui qui prévoyait la fixation
par le gouvernement de prix plancher
pour les billets d'avion considérant que
certaines compagnies aériennes n'était
pas à la hauteur de l'enjeu
environnemental
je crois que vous l'avez évoqué devant
nos collègues de l'assemblée nationale
ça ç'a permis au ministre de s'exprimer
petite parenthèse j'aime beaucoup le
ministre jebbari mais il avait une
position est assez critique sur l'avion
en juillet après
il est en position un petit peu
différente en décembre suite à ce que
vous avez dit à l'assemblée à
l'assemblée nationale enfin dernier
point concernant les objectifs que vous
vous êtes fixés sur le volume de
personnes et de marchandises à
transporter dans les dix prochaines
années qui va dans le sens de ce qu'on a
souhaité également dans le climat et
résilience et et que nous avons réussi à
faire inscrire dans le marbre de la loi
on
souhaiterait avoir confirmation que vous
serez en mesure de pouvoir
malgré les changements quelquefois
assez et la position assez ambiguë du
gouvernement qui dit on va à fond sur le
train du quotidien et d'un autre côté
qui décide de relancer des lignes à
grande vitesse et d'un autre côté on est
à fond sur le train du quotidien et jean
castex a annoncé lors d'epinal saint-dié
de la rouverture qu'il allait sauver
toutes les petites faire toutes les
petites lignes ferroviaires de toute
notre région de toutes nos régions donc
je sais que nos collègues sont très
contents de cette bonne nouvelle à
quatre mois d'une échéance importante
on sait qu'avec le rapport philizot il
faut pratiquement 700 millions d'euros
par an et quand dans notre commission et
dans notre assemblée nous avons proposé
un amendement pour doubler
le les sommes affectées
aux petites lignes ferroviaires donc
pour les passer d'environ 300 millions à
600 millions on s'est fait retoquer par
le gouvernement je vous parle même pas
de la commission mixte paritaire donc
tout ça pour vous dire que on a
l'impression qu'il ya une contradiction
entre les annonces qui sont faites et
entre ce qui nous est dit ici dans nos
différents débats donc sans vouloir vous
mettre en difficulté par rapport au
gouvernement
est ce que vous trouvez une cohérence à
cette politique
merci chers collègues obligée de me
répondre sur la sphère des questions on
veut vous gardez monsieur
messieurs jacques un
merci monsieur le président je poserai
six questions à l'excellent
non moins - oui - vous verrez - la
première sur le contexte social
il y à une grogne compréhensible suite à
ce que je considère comme la
maltraitance des cheminots durant ce
quinquennat qui ont été particulièrement
malmenées par le gouvernement vous
proposez 600 euros de prime au sol
cheminots de ces sncf voyageurs rien
dans les autres filiales ma question
c'est comment maintenir la cohésion
sociale d'un groupe public unifié si
cette expression encore un sens
ma deuxième question
j'observe qu'en bon politique que vous
êtes dans les deux années de crise que
vous avez cités vous avez bien parler de
la grève des retraites de duke au vide
mais pas des réformes incroyable que le
groupe a subi le nouveau pacte
ferroviaire qui contraint à revoir
considérablement le modèle alors
philippe tabarot a parlé de feu la
priorité trains du quotidien moi
j'observe qu'on est aussi à la fin du
tout tgv de fête avec un petit retour
des trains de nuit et notamment votre
filiale oslo service librement organisez
vous n'avez pas cité pour l'instant qui
semble être une perspective importante
alors vous annoncé un doublement du
nombre de voyageurs et de transport de
fret à l'horizon 2030 je tiens un
politiquement a salué un objectif aussi
vigoureux et or bercy vous gère toujours
sur la base du nouveau pacte ferroviaire
comme s'il n'y avait pas eu la crise du
code gide cf le contrat de performance
de sncf raisonnons n'a pas eu le droit
de le voir encore mais on le verra
peut-être un jour avec deux ou trois ans
de retard alors ma question ma deuxième
question c'est combien faudrait-il
investir dans l'infrastructure pour
atteindre les objectifs que vous évoquez
combien faudrait-il investir dans
l'infrastructure d'une part et d'autre
part dans le matériel roulant la
troisième question sera brève sur le
fret qui apparaît comme une incantation
politique et comme de l'agitation en
dépit de quelques annonces d'un plan
fret qu'il ya un progrès j'observe que
sncf réseau n'a aucun intérêt à faire
circuler des trains de fret sachez chers
collègues que ainsi on fret rapporte
presque dix fois moins quand il est payé
qu'un sion ter et donc je suis
responsable sncf réseau sur un
territoire si j'ai une concurrence entre
un train de voyageurs et un train de
fret je n'hésite pas donc il y à cette
question là je m'interroge même sur sncf
la holding de tête qui a une de ses
filiales les plus intéressantes geodis
qui est spécialiste du transport routier
donc là je vous pose la question de
manière synthétique comment sortir des
incantations politique en matière de
fret ma troisième question alors je vous
remercie d'avoir salué l'effort du sénat
dans la suppression des taxes la cst et
la trêve j'observe mes chers collègues
sans vouloir vous vexer que le groupe
socialiste et républicain était le seul
à porter ça dans l'avant dernier budget
et que ça a été repoussée ici par le
gouvernement et par la majorité
sénatoriale désolé d'être discourtois
mais c'est injuste
rappel c'est le président macron qui a
récupéré sa lors des quarante ans du tgv
est qui refaire l'amendement de la
victoire jean marx ou les i à
l'assemblée mais c'est une bonne chose
en finale on y est arrivé mais en même
temps c'est la fin du compte
d'affectation spéciale de financement
des trains d'équilibré du territoire
alors j'ai une question là dessus que
j'associe au fameux rapport sur les tmt
que nous avons obtenus sur initiative
parlementaire mais qui est sorti grâce à
mobile être la revue spécialisée passe
autrement celui ci comme le rapport
philizot on aurait jamais eu et ce
rapport excellent des montres des
besoins non satisfaits sur au moins cinq
grands sillons transversaux
donc ma question c'est à ma place que me
conseillez vous de préconiser au
gouvernement vous qui êtes un fin
politique pour mai en off ces lignes
nouvelles têtes et dont la liaison sud
de nancy du sillon lorrain vers lyon
grenoble que vous avez d'ailleurs fermé
en 2018 et ma cinquième question et
avant-dernière c'est qu'elle avait
manqué l'avenir au conventionnés dans
votre vision du ferroviaire
dernière question pour le pdg de sncf
quelle vision du service public
ferroviaire à 2030 ce n'est pas la même
question vous faites bien la nuance
j'observe à ce moment là vous avez
répondu sur rtl à mathieu klein le maire
de nancy qui s'indignent et la
suppression des 8 go desservant nancy
deuxième ville étudiante de france vous
avez dit on n'est pas dans le service
public alors que mathieu klein a été
contraint à financer la ligne lgv est ce
qu'ils supportent des uhnwi mais aussi
des 8 go je vous remercie
merci monsieur
le président je vous propose de répondre
à nos deux collègues qui est alors
maintenant je vais prendre le dialogue
social puisque monsieur tabarot lalala
mentionné monsieur jacquet lala est
resté plus plus dessus
alors c'est pas facile je sais c'est là
vous en prend rien ça fait partie des
caractéristiques de l'entreprise d'avoir
une rugosité social assez importante
quand je suis arrivé fin 2019 c'était 7
et terry 20 le climat social était très
dégradées suite à des réformes
successives
que les syndicats avaient ressenti qu'on
entende passage en force et donc il ya
une forme de ressenti même d'humiliation
par certains syndicats qui qui qui
préjugés mal de l'ambiance un don
c'était compliqué bon on a essayé de
travailler leur plus on a démarré par la
traite tout de suite ce qui était un
exercice forcément
d'applications racketter qui étaient
passés non plus bon c'était pas la
réforme essentielle c'était celle de
voulu pour le lancement du pays donc qu
on s était pas spécifique à notre
entreprise à travers le coc vide on a
retrouvé aussi l'occasion de se parler
et ça je voulais le souligner si on a
réussi à traverser le coc vide sans trop
de problèmes sncf c'est parce que avec
les syndicats le suivi à log et sur
comment on introduisait les gestes
sanitaires dans les gestes des métiers
des différents métiers
beaucoup de travail beaucoup de
concertation ça a payé ça a payé puisque
les syndicats et dont les personnels ont
été associés à l'adaptation d'entreprise
à cette crise et au fond ils ont répondu
présent à chaque fois il ya eu vraiment
aucun doute que difficultés sociales et
evo faut rendre hommage à l'euro à
l'engagement parce qu'au début on se
souvient pas de masque et c'était quand
même ils ont été là ils sont sortis de
chez eux dans les poses aiguillages dans
les cabines de conduite dans les gares
ils ont été présents dans les chantiers
tout ça tout ça s'est poursuivi là
maintenant on a on a à nouveau une
tension qui ce qui s'explique par une
toile de fond et des motifs plus
classique la toile de fond on l'a évoqué
c'est là on voit la concurrence la
sortie du coup vide un peu quand même
qui perturbe un peu les esprits et qui
fatigue tout le monde il ya aussi un
état de fatigue à la sncf comme chez les
français c'est une période difficile
pour tout le monde et les cheminots ils
font partie des français et donc aussi
sont là ses parts dans cette ambiance
morose difficile lié à cette crise
sanitaire
deuxièmement il ya la concurrence
il ya plusieurs facteurs là derrière il
ya cette histoire de transfert des
personnels forcément les gens concernés
n'avaient pas prévu que la suite de leur
carrière pourrait se faire en acier de
notre opérateur donc ça aussi c'est un
choc culturel important il faut
absolument les rassurer sur les
conditions dans lesquelles il pourrait
être amené à travailler chez d'autres
opérateurs comme ça va être le cas en
région paca puisque c'est une autre
compagnie qui a gagné 3 fo pas la citer
un seul gène pas du tout de la cité donc
il ya des questions légitimes sur qu'est
ce qui va se passer pour eux pour chacun
deuxièmement la concurrence à venir
aussi compétitivité c'est comme ça pour
l'accepter en tout cas moi je n'accepte
et compétitivité ça veut dire ajustement
des coûts puisque dans les dents les
facteurs de compétition nous serons
confrontés à des gens dans les
délégations de service public des
nouveaux entrants qui vont proposer des
prix attractifs il faut absolument que
la sncf puisse aligner sinon il sera
décrochée sur les décrocheurs ne sera
pas choisi ce n'est pas choisie on
perdra les marchés et on se retrouve
avec encore plus de cheminots transférer
que c'était et c'est donc on n'a pas le
choix il faut assumer affronter j'allais
dire ce sujet de compétitivité si on
veut pouvoir s'en sortir dans le futur
et ça ça veut dire quoi mais attention
sur l'emploi tensions sur les salaires
c'est pas facile ça c'est la toile de
fond il faut l'intégrer c'est un moment
compliqué pour l'entreprise deuxièmement
il ya les sujets plus classiques
notamment sur les salaires les cheminots
sont comme les français ils sont soumis
à des problèmes de pouvoir d'achat on a
en a on a un salaire moyen qui est
correct mais il veut rien dire le
salaire moyen de jeu le site pas parce
que ce sont des moyennes on a beaucoup
quand même de salaire modeste à la sncf
un des gens qui gagne 1500 1800 2000
euros net par mois il y en a beaucoup
donc c'est pas des gros salaires il faut
être honnête et est donc eu comme les
autres sont soumis à ces pressions on a
vu le coût de l'électricité etc et donc
ils demandent à ce que leur condition
salariale soit améliorée et c'est
légitime on peut pas à la hausse à se
compliquer pour un dirigeant c'est l'ex
quoi les marges de manoeuvre d'abord je
vous rappelle compétitivité donc si je
suis trop généreux à court terme je vais
renforcer ma difficulté de compétitif
dans faut articuler les enjeux de court
terme et les enjeux de long terme
et deuxièmement on parle d'une
entreprise en perte la sncf la 2020 3
milliards d'euros peu de 8,3 milliards
d'euros père 2021 c'est pas clos mais ce
sera un milliard et demi de milliards
d'euros de perte donc c'est compliqué
pour une entreprise en perte d'être
généreux ce plan salarial il ya aussi
des dires le réconcilier l'économique et
le social c'est dans les deux sens
l'économie doit tenir compte du social
et donc doit veiller à ce que les
cheminots soit associé trouver des
compromis on essaye mais le socialo
tenir compte l'économique voilà les deux
marchent ensemble c'est quoi ces masses
et mon opinion certains d'entre vous
vont sauf peut être en désaccord et
cette opinion et je les accepte bien
volontiers quand on applique ça au sujet
qui est présent les difficultés qu'on a
sont de nature essentiellement
salariales notamment sur le tgv sud-est
et et elle me surprennent pas ce qu'on a
eu des négociations salariales je trouve
assez assez assez nourris je rappelle
que malgré cette situation économique de
l'entreprise en a justement fait du
social en fait on va on va donner sur
une ce qu'on appelle en langage
salariale la rémunération mensuelle des
personnels présents la fameuse rmpp qui
mesure en fait le vrai taux
d'augmentation des salaires 2,7 pour
cent entre 2022 et demie 20h02 12 7%
donc quand vous entendez dire que les
salaires sont pas augmentés sncf c'est
pas vrai ce qui n'est pas augmentée si
la valeur du point comme pour les
fonctionnaires les points de gris sont
pas augmentés mais mais il ya des
avancements il ya les avancements
justement de gris statutaire des
positions de rémunérations qui sont
accordées tous les ans des passages à
niveau des augmentations de
qualification des promotions etc donc
voilà ça ça fait chaque année ça fait
environ 2% et on a complété ce
dispositif par un certain nombre de
mesures d'abord on a
orienté une prime vers l'est vers les
petits salaires on a une prime pouvoir
d'achat de 600 euros jusqu'à une 1,5
fois le smic qu'on a rajouté on l'a fait
pour tous les cheminots qui rentre dans
cette condition 1 pour un salaire
inférieur à 1 5 fois le smic
deuxièmement non non non pour tous les
jeux vidéo je viendrai la voyageurs
après tout les cheminots 600 euros pour
tous les cheminots quant au salaire
inférieur ou égal à 1,5 fois le smic on
a rajouté on à déplafonner la grille
statutaire sur les trois collèges
exécution maîtrise et cadres comme les
gens partent à leur gré de plus en plus
tard plus vieux plus âgés il plafonne en
fin de grille il arrive à l'affinerie il
plafonne et il y reste dix ans 12 ans on
a décoincé 7,7 cette fin de carrière en
rajoutant eu au moins une position de
rémy sur nous une perspective
d'augmentation de la même manière dans
la même logique on a mis un échelon
d'ancienneté supplémentaires on a
rajouté un échelon dans cette équipe a
encore d'une possibilité de progression
jusqu'à la fin de sa carrière et ça
compte pour le calcul de la retraite
bien sûr dans une logique de régine
spécial vous savez ces six derniers mois
qui compte donc chaque euro qu'on peut
gagner dans les six derniers mois il va
se répercuter mécaniquement dans le
calcul de la retraite voilà on a
augmenté le nombre de promotions de
niveau en niveau 2 donc on a fait
beaucoup de choses je trouve dans les
marges de manoeuvre qui étaient les
nôtres je le rappelle qui était limité
et d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs je il ya une
traduction sociale de cet effort c'est
que deux syndicats et non des moindres
l'unsa les autonomes qui est 2e syndicat
et la cfdt qu'on connaît donc on est le
sérieux ont signé cet accord salarial
donc il ya eu un engagement de deux
syndicats qui ont perçu les avancées sur
ce paquet là la s1 voyageur vous
l'évoquez monsieur sénateurs à anticiper
un calcul d'intéressement parce que
c'est vrai car juste avant la grève
j'espère qu'elle n'aura pas lieu les
résultats de deux tgv était bon on a
fait un très bon automne un septembre
octobre novembre pour ceux qui prennent
le train je pense que vous rendez compte
que les communes sont bien remplies et
un vrai rebond dans les trains oui et
est donc vrai rebond dans l'es13 ça veut
dire bien sûr beaucoup de travail pour
les salariés dans les gares
voilà donc il ya beaucoup de monde les
trains d'ordon l'ice un voyageur a
souhaité récompenser traduire cet
élément de bonne santé économique et
commerciale car une espèce d'avant sur
intéressement c'est les fameux 600 euros
la somme est la même dans d'où la
confusion est possible mais les salariés
les savoyards c'est un sur deux camps et
donc tous les conducteurs de trains
voyageurs qui en font partie ont aussi
touché 600 euros de plus cela tous n'y a
pas de limites de salaires voilà et là
dessus on voit apparaître au dernier
moment alors qu'on est très près des
départs en vacances est ce que c'est un
hasard chacun pourra considérer cette
question une tension supplémentaire au
plan local on n'est plus au plan
national alors ce plan local qui soit
quand vous avez lé conducteur du tgv sud
est ça se voit qu'ils demandent encore
des compléments voile alors là dessus on
est au bout du bout de la limite les
négociations se poursuivent là au moins
on a négocié depuis plusieurs jours
encore hier soir tard le directeur les
tensions locales négocie on essaie de
mais il ya une limite c'est limite on
n'est pas loin de l'avoir atteinte voilà
donc j'espère que ces derniers efforts
qui seront créées les conditions de de
levée du préavis les discussions sont en
cours vraiment on se parle je croise les
doigts on sera fixé vers midi ou 14
heures à m'en donnez nous devrons
prendre acte de la situation et annoncé
des plans transport qui rouleront sur
lequel nous engageons à partir de
vendredi voilà donc c'est aujourd'hui
c'est la voilà donc c'est cette ambiance
là qui est la nôtre
je reviens surtaxe ferroviaire tva 5,5
mois jusqu'à maintenant je suis pour
voilà je sais pas ce qui a dit que la
sncf était pas d'accord moi j'suis
d'accord mais évidemment puisque ça
permettrait de rendre le transport moins
chers or on sait que l'accès l'accès par
le prix est très important ça peut être
une gêne pour les pour des familles
modestes pour prendre le train donc tout
ce qui pourra concourir à réduire le
prix du train est le bienvenu voilà et
c'est pas des bigeard nation passe de 20
à 5 5 ça fait un sacré écart voilà donc
moi je suis évidemment favorable ça vous
permet de clarifier la situation où ma
position si ça devait être fait
l'ouverture à la concurrence sur la
résilience et vraiment on s'en sort pas
trop mal franchement je fais très
attention à l'indépendance de réseau je
le cite souvent en exemple mais c'est
vrai il faut je vous demande de me
croire je ne savais pas avant que ça
sorte dans la presse à quel jour combien
train etc de trenitalia je ne le savais
pas voilà donc je n'ai pas posé la
question mon collègue de réseaux élus de
marianne voilà donc vraiment je fait
très très attention à respecter
scrupuleusement
l'étanchéité par rapport à réseau que
réseau décide je ne sais pas qui se
présente qui devant des sillons à quelle
heure je ne sais pas et je ne veux pas
savoir voilà donc ça marche ça marche et
franchement trenitalia a réussi à lancer
ses trains transdev a réussi à gagner un
contrat parce que la région provence
côte d'azur elle même avait réussi à
organiser d'appel d'offres donc on a des
démonstrateurs que ça marche maintenant
j'entends certains dire que ça ne marche
pas moi je pose ses démonstrations ça
marche la preuve c'est qu'une région a
su regagner son appel d'offres ayant
concurrents a su arriver sur les sur les
tgv ceux qui se plaignent au fond quand
on regarde ses parts qu'ils ne
maîtrisent pas encore suffisamment la
spécificité la technique ferroviaire
cantonnement de cendrillon sortir au
dernier moment de faire bordeaux lyon on
a des problèmes parce qu'il ya des
travaux parce qu'à d'autres trains voilà
au dernier moment c'est pas facile de
trouver un sillon ce bordeaux lyon donc
forcément réseau est obligé de dire
désolé non je peux pas de bonne foi il
le dirait de la même manière à la sncf
c'est sais pas ont-ils le nouvel entrant
c'est parce que c'est la réalité
technique de la manière les italiens ont
su adapter leur tgv aux as médiation
française ils ont demandé rien à
personne ils sont débrouillés comme nous
on a fait 1 espagne d'ailleurs on n'a
rien demandé à personne on l'a fait les
espagnols ont du mal mais ils ont du mal
c'est pas la faute ni de réseau qui
s'occupera des matériels roulants dit la
sncf voyageurs qui a passé occupé de
matériels roulants des espagnols est
quand même un peu curieux bon disons des
difficultés dans tactiles ont des
difficultés c'est je vois pas pourquoi
on nous en voudraient les difficultés
qu'ils rencontrent vers là il ya quelque
chose qui me paraît un peu un peu
surprenant mais bon voilà donc je pense
qu'il faut bien préciser tout ça sur
sur les modes de transport je le redis
en sincérité un moment concurrencer le
mode routier à la fois pour les
marchandises les camions en gros est la
voiture la voiture c'est la voiture
particulière le mode routier il fait 85
% des déplacements pour le fret qu'on
fait pour les marchandises comme pour
les voyageurs le trend en fait disent si
on fait simple 11 et 9 mai mettons 10
pour faire des rondes il faut faire des
calculs simplement fait ce que je
voudrais c'est prendre 10 points de part
de marché à la route en voyageur comment
fait et les rajouter aux dix points du
fer dispute dit ça fait vingt le foie de
ses salles de calcul c est ce qu'on est
capable de prendre dix points parmi 85
10 en garde récente rien dans le coran
il serait pas dévasté 1 je pense que
c'est possible mais pas facile et ça
suppose de choses dont les
infrastructures dont des politiques
commerciales qualité de service etc etc
mais il ya du boulot pour y arriver mais
la vision macro c'est autour de ça
l'aérien alors souvent on nous fait on
me fait me fricoter avec l'aérien et ses
profits lee s'est passé pas complètement
ça le sujet je pense que le fond c'est
plutôt une complémentarité avec l'aérien
je pense que si on prend un peu de recul
il ya des zones de pertinence pour aller
à new york on va pas le faire en train à
l'évidence par contre pour aller à
marseille j'aime bien que le fasse enfin
voilà donc voila mais voilà je pense que
quand les trajets sont accessibles en
train je trouverai bien que le train
soit privilégiée pour des raisons
écologiques à l'évidence ur de la
moyenne 10 ans ou la longue distance
l'avion apporte un service que le trait
ne pourra pas faire rester très nuit qui
sont des petites niches où on peut
voyager en normands reviennent et paris
je pense que ça a son sens alors il ya
des gens qui sont prêts à passer la nuit
dans le train il trouve ça agréable on
n'arrive pas trop tard dans la ville à
destination voilà mais si les volumes
sont pas très importants voilà la
confrontation avec l'aérien n'est pas un
gros enjeu de volume voilà donc faut
garder son sang froid le vrai sujet
c'est la route
j'aurais parlé le nouveau pacte on en a
parlé j'en ai un peu parlé pardon vous
et tti à oslo si c'est la même un peu la
même chose alors oslo ancien nom de code
en fait la sncf s'est rendu compte que
justement il y avait un retour du slow
slow life un peu des gens qui avaient le
temps il ya des gens qui ont le temps il
n'y a pas que les gens pressés il y
aussi des gens qui ont le temps et qui
sont prêts à voyager plus longtemps si
les prix sont bas et dans le trade off
comme on dit en bon français on m'offre
si j'ai un prix intéressant je suis prêt
finalement à prendre une heure ou deux
de plus pour aller à lyon pour aller à
nantes bon et est donc premièrement
deuxièmement et c'est avec du matériel
roulant dont plan telles qu'elles
utilisaient pas amorti comme on dit donc
enfin le coup de capital il est égal à
zéro ça fait longtemps que ses amorties
et cora elle a rénové un peu des corails
l'a fait les trains ça fait des prix des
billets à 15 euros 20 euros pour aller à
nantes pour aller à lyon traînent jour 1
prend son temps mais quatre heures on
voit défiler le paysage c'est pas mal
pour qu'on le ferait pas voilà on ne
vend pas de subventions on prend notre
risque on le fait ça fait de l'emploi
des repassages ont créé des services
nouveaux on va tester on va tester si un
marché pour ça en fait ce qu'on vit
c'est le marché du bus un peu on vient
on revient un peu en concurrence là pour
le coup avec ces bus longue distance dit
voilà qu'on a pu connaître ces derniers
temps un peu la voiture particulière
aussi voilà je pense qu'il ya une niche
quelque part ça fera pas des volumes
importants mais je pense qu'ils
raisonnent de pertinence un peu comme le
celi qui est vendu très nuit le jour
quand il ya un peu de cette idée là on
prend son temps pour voyager les prix
sont pas trop élevés on a quelque chose
de confortable et de sueur on prend le
train voilà sur les trains d'équilibré
du territoire la nouvelle convention est
en discussion avec l'état donc là c'est
l'état qui est l'autorité organisatrice
vous le savez on aimerait bien la signer
début 2000 22 peut-être avec le
gouvernement actuel ce serait bien il
faudrait d'ailleurs puisque l'année 2022
et la première année du nouveau contrat
a priori c'est pour six ans avec des
clauses qui permettrait à l'état qu'un
de mettre en concurrence des lignes s'il
le souhaitait pendant cette période là
après tout ça peut être lors décision et
nous l'acceptons bien sûr il ya le sujet
du périmètre qui a été évoquée par
philippe tabarot là une expression
politique comme vous j'écoute ce que dit
le gouvernement j'écoute ce que des
ministres et transporte pas plus tard
que ces derniers jours il affiche une
envie de développer ses trains à la fois
de jour comme de nuit après bien sûr et
on verra s'ils sont inscrits dans le
contrat oui ou non kouassi sont pas
inscrits ça restera une vision un petit
peu un petit peu lointaine s'il arrive
dans le contrat c'est à dire que pour de
vrai le gouvernement a vraiment décidé
de les faire l'enjeu l'a aussitôt
l'enjeu économique c'est souvent le haut
ça se termine souvent par des sujets en
euros il sait déjà le rôle de
l'acquisition de la flotte les trains
corail sont au bout du rouleau il faut
vraiment acheter des nouveaux trains et
les nouvelles locomotives pour les
tracter parce que nos locomotives elles
ont 40 ans et sont à bout de souffle
donc il faudra que l'état dans ce cas-là
trouve du coi lui-même articule 800
millions d'euros 1 pour acheter à la
fois les rangs
28 rames 28 vous êtes une nouvelle rame
les voitures les voitures et locomotives
donc ça il ya un sujet budgétaire qui
apparaîtra abandonné capacité de l'état
l'état pensant d'ailleurs aussi dans les
modalités à une société de location de
deux trains embrouille une société
investir et dans les trains et les
lourds et à l'état qui les mettrait à
disposition de l'opérateur il ya
peut-être des schémas comme ça qu'ils
sont en train d'être étudiées il faut
surveiller si vraiment on y arrive
voilà le foie de l'incantation politico
réalité c'est un vrai sujet bien sûr
et vous avez raison en fait j'ai dit mon
raisonnement leur demande d'introduction
on est un peu au pied du mur comme le
maçon
on y va on y va pas quoi on va peut pas
être à moitié si vraiment et ça et
j'espère que ces débats vont arriver
dans le débat démocratique évoqué par
les uns par les autres pour le moment on
est beaucoup sur les sujets importants
et je les vois là ils ont lieu d'être
sécurité immigration qui ont de bien
occuper le terrain j'espère comment
donner on basculera sur d'autres sujets
dont dont la transition écologique que
devient la france dans ce que l'on
relève ce défi là si on ne prend le
raisonnement il est assez implacable me
semble-t-il sur ces attaques pour de
vrai on est obligé de passer par la case
mobilité et transport parce que c'est le
premier émetteur 30% des gaz à effet de
serre viennent du secteur mobilité au
sens large à les camions les avions les
bateaux les voitures les trains et c'est
toute la mobilité bon faut s'y attaquer
de 30% sur ces attaques il ya deux
manières de s'attaquer peut-être faut-il
faire les deux d'ailleurs mais
intellectuellement il faut quand même
bien les discerner celle qui va plus
vite c'est le report modal démo de
polluants la route le camion la voiture
vers le train c'est ce qui va le plus
vite voilà faut décider pour l'inciter
des mesures fiscales des mesures
d'accompagnement et cetera dans une
dizaine d'années on peut faire déjà une
grosse partie du travail et ça va
nourrir le x 2 d'ailleurs voyez tout ça
est très cohérent je sais aussi pour
être honnête intellectuellement
avez-vous ils veulent être que comme je
lui ai dit le train va pas tout prendre
donc on va aussi s'attaquer pendant ses
dix ans à la recherche et développement
sur comment verdi les camions comment
verdi les avions comment verdi les
bateaux comment verdi les voitures et
comment comment fournit l'électricité à
d un parc automobile en millions de
voitures donc il ya des gros sujets là
derrière je sais qui oui il ya des gros
sujets mais laissait penser qu'ils sont
résolus dans un homme paraît là une
illusion alors que le train est là le
train il ya de la place dans les trains
la place dans les ter il ya de la place
on peut faire des trains en plus elle la
place dans les trains de fret on peut
déjà compléter l'offre existante
on peut créer la créer des
infrastructures pour le que voilà dans
une dizaine d'années on peut vraiment
voilà donc moi je dit l'urgence et le
report modal et bien sûr il faut aussi
travailler en recherche et développement
dans des solutions industrielles pour
réinventer les modes les mode routier de
demain qui serait pas polluant je ne
néglige pas à ce sujet mais je pense
qu'il vient après il a les solutions
sont pas prêtes quoique certains en
disent pour leur boulot de lobby pour
défendre vos intérêts mais si on regarde
franchement les choses je pense pas
qu'il soit prêt dans les délais alors
que le ferroviaire lui il est dans les
starting blocks il est prêt il est prêt
à y aller voilà c'est un peu ma réponse
à sa trêve testé on l'a dit merci encore
à tous les parlementaires cgpi qualité
sont clés parce que aujourd'hui lé
paradoxe est que le mode ferrée et le
moins polluant il le plus taxé cherchez
l'erreur quoi donc il faut en terme
d'égalité fiscale il faut calmer les
choses à faire et deuxièmement vous
connaissez ce sujet qui est un peu aride
mais qui est central c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'effet intégré internaliser les
coûts externes que ça ses clés parce que
c'est quand même une réalité l'europe
d'ailleurs s'en occupe l'europe est
faite est assez à lens il ya le green
deal vous savez en ce moment au niveau
européen je pense que côté français
aussi faut qu'on accepte ce débat qui
est un débat facile parce que la
traduction fiscal de tout ça est
sensible et je le sais bien voilà mais
n'empêche que c'est un sujet qui est sur
la table il faudra qu'on arrive à
progresser dans une forme d' avoir
d'égalité fiscale entre les modes et
pourquoi pas d'encourager les modes plus
ou moins pour le monde par rapport à
ceux qui le sont davantage sur une
certaine logique à rentrer dans ce dans
dans ces schémas
alors j'ai des questions peu
philosophique sur le conventionnés le
service public le conventionnés c'est la
sphère des autorités organisatrices
moi j'ai confiance je pense que j'étais
justement le président le site et
j'étais présent à l'inauguration de
dunes les pinal seigner ou seigner
epinal j'ai été une fois que je le sais
je n'ai pas découvert mais je me suis à
nouveau aperçu à quel point les
territoires les élus des territoires les
habitants du territoire sont attachés à
leur ligne il y en a ça vous le savez
tous et c'est le rôle des sénateurs est
sûre si vous le savez tous bon ça vous
le savez vous le vivez tous bons mais ça
je vois donc donc donc donc cet
attachement des français dans les
territoires laureline ferroviaire il est
fort il ne faiblit pas ll ne faiblit pas
il augmente même parce qu'avec la
sensibilité écologique il augmente et
donc je suis convaincu que les autorités
organisatrices les régions pour faire
court ou ile-de-france mobilité en ile
de france vont continuer vont poursuivre
cette politique de d'amélioration du
ferroviaire de d'augmenter l'offre
ferroviaire c'est le sens de la
concurrence et compris aussi que la
concurrence avait pour effet de dégager
des marges de manoeuvre qui permettrait
de poursuivre le développement auquel il
logique je suis convaincu moi que le
service public ferroviaire en fait vrai
service public celui qui est dirigé par
les autorités organisatrices avec ils
sont légitimes en la matière il a de
l'avenir il faudra que ce surplus
intermodal je pense qu'on a encore un
chantier sur la capacité à combiner le
train et les autres mode là il ya du
boulot encore comment on vient en
voiture comment on peut se garer comment
c'est facile
information la tarification l'écart les
bus tous à connecter au train les vélos
etc on a un énorme chantier et moi je
pense que c'est vous avez compris que
son optimiste mais il faut l'être je
pense qu'on peut il ya des solutions
dans les zones rurales je pense que les
gens qui sont les zones rurales il
rêverait de pas prendre leur voiture ils
sont obligés de prendre leur voiture
aujourd'hui comment on arrive pour de
vrai alors proposer une offre
alternative voilà je suis prêt à engager
les sens' et dans des réflexions dans
des groupes de travail pour arriver à
tester des solutions qu'est-ce qu'il
faut proposer aux français dans les
zones rurales pour qu'ils puissent tout
simplement se passer de la voiture voilà
je pense ce sujet il est clé et je suis
prêt il travaillait donc voilà donc je
suis confiant la suite je pense que
c'est je voie de l'avenir à ces sujets
là sur le rôle de service public sncf ou
une réponse un peu juridique que j'ai
fait que j'ai fait à monsieur le maire
de nancy il faut être clair là-dessus on
n'est pas compensée sur les personnes ou
qu on pense alors c'est vrai que les
collectivités ont participé au
financement la ligne mais dans le
déficit d'exploitation c'est nous qui le
pronom on le prend voilà donc aussi
celle services publics font de le dire
mais dans ce cas là faut accepter une
compensation moi je reviens ce qu'on a
dit sur la péréquation
si on me dit que je suis compenser si
j'assure des dessertes tgv non rentables
je suis prêt à discuter bien évidemment
si on me disait ah non tu dois
débrouiller avec tp âge avec le couteau
matériel roulant des coûts salariaux etc
etc là je vais être obligé de plus en
plus de faire attention à l' équilibre
de ses lignes voilà on peut pas en
vouloir d'autant plus qu'on a fait de
moi une société anonyme on a fait 2 - le
président que vous citez anonyme le
mandataire social une société anonyme ça
entraîne des obligations juridiques
quasiment pénale attention aux acteurs
normands de gestion etc etc ça a été
voulue par le législateur
cette rigueur économique faut pas nous
la reprocher ni à moigné mon collègue de
réseaux excellent hier mon collègue de
voyageurs voilà nous ne faisons
qu'appliquer finalement l'esprit de la
loi et les conditions juridiques dans
lequel on nous a misé alors c'est vrai
que c'est un changement par rapport peut
être à une souplesse ou une une comment
dire une zone d'ombré une zone de gris
dans lesquelles ont été installés je
pense que l'intervention du législateur
ça a été de même le coup de projecteur
là dessus et de bien dissocier qui était
services publics ce qui n'était pas ou
ce qu'il était plus voilà je pense que
ça c'est un élément très nouveau et ont
en tout cas je le vis comme ça et je
vois bien c'est parfois une source de
malentendus avec les élus et je peux le
comprendre puisque la pédagogie n'a pas
été fait encore c'est à nous de faire
bien expliquer la réforme qu'est ce que
ça veut dire c'est quoi nos droits mais
aussi non obligations etc etc voilà
j'entends que c'est un sujet qui n'est
pas complètement clarifier avec avec les
élus et c'est à moi de le faire à nous
de le faire voilà j'espère avoir à peu
près répondu aux questions posées
merci monsieur le président donc il ya
pour votre information il ya 17 demandes
de parole donc si vous mettez deux
minutes ça fait 34 2 minutes au
président pour répondre ça fait une
heure dix voilà je voulais avant donc je
vais donner la parole à nicole bonnefoy
oui je vais essayer d'être rapide merci
monsieur le président monsieur président
de la sncf le train aujourd'hui le
mérite d'être le moyen de transport
préféré des français vous l'avez dit il
constitue à ce titre un atout majeur
pour répondre à nos enjeux
environnementaux pourtant il apparaît
que bien trop souvent la sncf ne
parvient pas à répondre à la demande des
usagers trop souvent en effet des
voyageurs se retrouvent démunis d'avoir
une liste de trains complets avant de se
résoudre un puissant et faute de
propositions alternatives à reporter
leur trajet au lendemain ou à choisir un
mode de transport plus polluants et je
voudrais la cité l'exemple de lax
atlantique qui est révélateur de ce
désengagement progressif de la sncf
exemple était 2021 alors que les
résultats donc de l'été de mai 2021
démontré une réelle reprise du trafic
des voyageurs sur le sud ouest vous avez
supprimé sur cette même période 20 % des
sièges offerts quotidiennement par
rapport à 2019 où est donc la posture de
conquête que vous avez promise cette
situation a eu des conséquences bien
évidemment très concrètes sur la qualité
de l'offre de transport depuis plusieurs
mois une grande partie des trains
proposés en semaine affiche complet
quelles que soient leurs quinze jours
avant le départ octobre novembre
décembre y compris hors vacances
scolaires que ce soit vers ou depuis
barbes bordeaux cette situation nuit à
la qualité du service proposé à la
clientèle business qui utilisent le
train en heures de pointe et en première
classe elle nuit également la clientèle
loisirs car la rareté des sièges se
ressent sur les prix y compris we go
alors que vous premier tier en début
d'année de frapper très fort sur
l'accessibilité tarifaire face au
mécontentement des élus locaux vous
venez vous l'avez si tu es qui pour
rappel ont contribué aux investissements
majeurs de cette ligne et qui donc
escompter des justes retombées pour leur
économie leur emploi et leur
attractivité
sncf prévoit toujours de poursuivre la
réduction tendancielle de l'offre vers
le sud ouest pour 2022 cette baisse de
l'offre est d'autant plus surprenante au
regard des conséquences notamment
environnementales qui implique de fait
l'offre va à conduire les usagers qui
n'auront pas d'autre choix d'utiliser
des modes de transport plus polluants ce
retrait est d'autant plus surprenant que
la disparition de la navette aérienne
bordeaux orly aurait dû se traduire par
un renforcement afin d'absorber ces
nouveaux voyageurs alors ma question
est la suivante alors que le dynamisme
de la demande n'est plus à prouver
la sncf prévoit tél enfin vraiment
d'assurer sa mission de service public
en enfonçant son offre sur l'axé
atlantique et d'une manière générale sur
toutes les lignes concernées par ce
phénomène je tiens à poser cette
question dans une logique de long terme
et indépendamment des aléas sanitaires
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui parce
que la sncf n'ont en effet pas attendu
lakovic 19 pour réduire son offre
notamment sur l'axé atlantique
elle était réduite bien avant est-ce que
par un manque de matériel roulant
sachant que de nombreuses rames ont été
envoyées en espagne pour assurer la
liaison madrid barcelone merci je vais
donner la parole à rémy pointereau puis
à
bruno belin et à stéphane demilly oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur
président
ferrandou deux questions une sur les
projets lgv puisque ça a été évoqué tout
à l'heure on parle de relancer bordeaux
toulouse montpellier perpignan et puis
on a lyon turin
qui est qui a démarré qu'en est il du
poc paris orléans clermont lyon guette
une ligne qui a un double objectif à la
fois des saturé par idiot mais aussi de
faire de l'aménagement du territoire je
crois que ça c'est important et je pense
qu'avec la nouvelle à l'arrivée de deux
nouvelles lignes ça devrait accélérer la
saturation de paris lyon
et en plus on a un moyen de transport
qui est le plus vertueux qui permet de
conclure en ces quelques par l'avion la
deuxième question concerne les
conventions sncf avec l'arrêt de les
régions les fécos vide a effectivement
fait chuter la fréquentation sur les
lignes et à creuser le déficit de
certaines lignes régionales
pour la région centre c'est 90 millions
d'euros
apparemment il ya une négociation qui a
fait que la région de perret que 30
millions d'euros sur ce déficit
comment vous financer des 60 millions
d'euros
restants est-ce que ça va pas pénaliser
quand même aussi la sncf
merci beaucoup
merci président je vous ai mis à écouter
ce président là sur la fin de votre
dernière intervention et on et vous
parlez de
d'essayer de convaincre les ruraux de se
passer de leur voiture
et comment vous comptez vous prendre
pour convaincre les routes se passer de
leur voiture quand on sait que c'est le
seul moyen sûr de nombreux territoires
pour aller à des rendez-vous médicaux
des places les déplacements des enfants
sur leurs activités enfin
voilà donc si
je suis confiant et optimiste sur la
ruralité mais aujourd'hui je expliquez
moi comment on va faire
pour se passer de sa voiture en milieu
rural
merci stéphane demi merci beaucoup je
président farandou je suis sénateur des
hauts de france et cette seule phrase
suffit à introduire ce qui va suivre et
l'irritation que vous risqueriez de
déceler dans mes propos en ajoutant que
je suis un sénateur usagers réguliers
des lignes amiens paris ou plus
exactement de ce président j'essaie de
l'être pour résumer l'exaspération
des usagers quotidiens du thé vert
concernés retenons que la région des
hautes france en dernière position des
classements de régularité depuis
septembre dernier c'est l'horreur à tel
point que fin octobre la sncf a déployé
un plan d'urgence pour remédier à cette
situation extrêmement dégradée sur ce
réseau et un courrier du directeur
régional monsieur guichard évoqué un
retour à la normale fin novembre quand
la situation est encore plus
catastrophique
un mois plus tard les usagers sont
amassés dans des trains plein à craquer
sans raison sans réseau sans connexion
internet souvent sans chauffage et
parfois sans lumière la région hôte
france dépense près d'un demi milliard
d'euros par an sans compter les
investissements pour transporter 200
mille voyageurs par jour c'est cher payé
pour un triste service et je comprends
l'irritation du président bertrand
devant cette situation inacceptable
la suspension immédiate du paiement de
décembre pour le fonctionnement des ter
est critiquable mais elle a au moins
pour mérite de jeter un pavé dans la
marre qu'il y ait des difficultés liées
à la crise sanitaire nous pouvons
comprendre qu'il y ait des difficultés
ponctuelles liées au contexte climatique
nous pouvons le comprendre mais que ce
soit systématique et qu'on découvre que
les feuilles tombent en automne et qu'il
y ait parfois de la neige en hiver ça on
a du mal à le comprendre monsieur le
président à quand une réelle
amélioration je dis bien réel du réseau
de transport dans les autres ans un camp
à un plan marshall pour que les usagers
des autres on se retrouve effectivement
confiance en la sncf
et pour nous
enfin un mot tu parles de l'hexagone non
bon
je vais donner la parole à monsieur
bastille et à monsieur gold monsieur
fassi monsieur gold cup challenge
donnerait la parole au président a enfin
rendu pour répondre je suivais merci
président j'apporte une question dans
notre collègue est un etienne blanc
sénateur de ronald cette question
concerne le projet lyon turin auquel
vous avez publiquement apporté un
soutien remarqué il ya quelques semaines
en soulignant ses enjeux stratégiques et
écologiques comme sous vous le savez la
clé de voûte de cette liaison le tunnel
franco-italien de 57 kilomètres et demi
sous les alpes est en cours de percement
pour une livraison à l'horizon 2040 or
un tel ouvrage n'a de sens que s'il est
correctement connectés de part et
d'autre côté italien le projet des
indispensables de oued accès au tunnel
transfrontalier été actée par le
gouvernement il ya quatre ans la section
italienne sera livrée en même temps que
le tunnel l'international avec une
capacité de fret de 25 mille tonnes par
an soit 162 train de marchandises par
jour de notre côté il n'y a toujours
aucun engagement sur la section
française alors que la développer date
de près de 10 à un processus d'étude de
phasage est en cours mais à ce jour la
priorité du gouvernement est toujours de
moderniser une ligne existante pour
porter sa capacité de fret à 10 millions
de tonnes par an soit environ 95 m par
jour autrement dit lorsque le tunnel
transfrontalier en droit en service les
capacités de la section italienne seront
2,5 fois supérieure à celle prévue du
côté français l'union européenne et
l'italie aux côtés desquels la france
s'est engagée à travers plusieurs
traités et accords internationaux
manifestent de plus en plus leur
impatience pendante à dire leur
agacement qu'est la clé quel éclairage
pouvait voir porté sur le manque de
cohérence et de coordination entre les
différentes sections du plus grand
chantier ferroviaire fret et voyageurs
européens
merci monsieur vol et amiel donat parole
au présent farandou merci on s'amuse le
président
vous avez parlé monsieur farandou des
grands objectifs moi je vais vous parler
un peu de déclinaisons locales en
évitant bien sûr de citer des lignes
particulières de mon département
j'aurais plutôt revenir sur les annonces
du premier ministre sur l'avenir des
petites lignes puisqu'il a fait des
annonces notamment lors de la
réouverture de la ligne et saint-dié
epinal
et promis la remise en état de neuf
mille deux cents kilomètres de petites
lignes voire même leur réouverture
ainsi que la signature de six protocoles
avec les région autorité organisatrice
de la mobilité
dans le puy-de-dôme les journalistes de
france 3 ont essayé d'avoir des
informations plus concrètes sur ces
annonces apparemment sans succès chacun
se renvoyait la balle entre entre lyon
et paris leur avez vous des éléments
plus précis un calendrier de la
déclinaison de ces annonces sur les
territoires pour tout vous dire avez
vous tout simplement des objectifs quant
à la signature des protocoles avec les
région autorité organisatrice de la
mobilité et puis par ailleurs certaines
lignes tht
ont besoin également de travaux et des
investissements sont programmées avec le
renouvellement de rames et la
régénération des lignes vous en avait
parlé dans vos propos initiaux
cette régénération malgré cette
génération cette régénération cours il
ya d'importantes perturbations sur
certaines niches par dollar il paraît
clairement d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
puisque les messages que je reçois tout
de suite la montre des difficultés avec
des retards de plus d'une heure qui sont
quand même assez fréquent
mais il ya eu des retards beaucoup plus
grand beaucoup plus longue notamment le
21 octobre où deux trains sont arrivés
avec plus de trois heures de retard et
le 1er novembre ou
le clairement paris a franchi les portes
de la capitale avec cette heure de
décalage sur l'horaire prévu alors je
peux comprendre qu'il ait des
difficultés les raisons sont diverses et
variées par contre je trouve que
des améliorations à faire sur la gestion
des crises
puisque les la gestion et laisse les
usagers sur leur faim défaut
d'information des lieux des motifs
exposés qui sont incompréhensibles voire
inconcevable pour le grand public alors
quelles pistes d'amélioration
pouvez-vous apporter sur la gestion de
ces crises que gestion qui est
difficilement
admissible par les usagers du rail
actuellement
merci monsieur plaisir ok donc je crois
compris qu'il fallait aller relativement
vite dont je vais le faire sur
l'atlantique - ma connaissance les
l'offre est redevenu est vraiment
revenue au niveau nominal les week-ends
et les jours de pointe et il peut y
avoir un petit ajustement à ma
connaissance on peut le vérifier mais là
c'est la face je ne conteste pas puisque
ça je vous dis moi ce que je sais mais
dès que je sais pas tout je sais qu'on a
aussi des problèmes de ram on a des
problèmes avec alstom de problème de
soudure etc qui font qu il manque 8
grammes à peu près donc forcément ça se
sent 1 quand il manque des rames voilà
mais sur la l'intention elle est bien de
redéployer l'offre au final jacques le
trafic revient mais peut-être aussi que
le trafic revient fort moi je me demande
si le trafic il va plus fort presque
avant parce que comme vous je prends le
train pour aller à bordeaux assez
régulièrement je constate que les trains
sont très remplie moi je le vois moi
aussi donc je vois pas pourquoi
délibérément on mettrait pas les trains
sur les avait on peut être confrontés à
des problèmes de parts qu'il faut que
nos besoins sur limité mais on va
regarder c'est ce sujet là pas la
première attiré mon attention là dessus
donc on va le regarder de près tu peux
vous rassurer que notre intention c'est
bien sûr d'offrir l'offre au maximum de
ce que nous avons pas encore le trafic
est là et vous avez raison de d'attirer
mon attention sur ce sujet qui est sourd
aux gars vous examen
/
alors les lits nouvelle donc la question
plutôt sur poc
poc pour se hisser paris orléans
clermont lyon danser une nouvelle ligne
qui doublerait effectivement la ligne
sud-est qui est bien plein ça c'est
exact à court terme les solutions
choisies c'est plutôt donner plus de
capacité lan sud-est et en mettant le
fameux ertms avec le système six nations
européens qui va dans les 25 %
sur clairement vous savez qu'il ya des
programmes sur une classique ça renvoie
aussi à la question qui a été évoqué
donc à la fois sur l'infrastructure qui
permettrait de la fiabiliser d'aller un
peu plus vite et sur les matériels
roulants je relis d'ailleurs avec cette
infrastructure et ce matériel on fera
pas des miracles il faut aussi être
clairs en fait je vais pas vous
promettre car la locomotive qui ont 40
ans des voitures qui ont autant on la
veut la voix qui a pas été entretenu par
le passé je serai comme à dire ne serait
pas
correct ouais si si je vous disais par
un coup de baguette magique tout va
s'arranger
donc on fait tout ce qu'on peut mais
avec des équipements très anciens les
guépards l'histoire c'est comme ça les
décisions n'ont pas été prises il ya
quelques années maintenant faire avec
les éditions futures sont prises il faut
le faire
rénovation sur la voie et puis
rénovation des matériels c'est 2025 je
crois l'arrivée des rats nouvelle en
attendant ça fait loin ça fait trois ans
a passé là vous avez entièrement raison
et la faut que je le prenne pour moi
dire que là les infos etc ça on doit
bien le faire il n'y a pas de raison
d'un problème locomotive c'est pas prêt
d'infrastructures dont je prends le
point et je vais regarder les équipes
comment on peut améliorer l'information
voyageur là vous avez entièrement raison
et c'est pas un problème
d'investissement lourd donc il faut il
faut savoir le faire
voilà donc pour que la bonne avis c'est
vraiment du très très long terme c'est
la vision stratégique le jour où la lgv
sera vraiment saturé donc on sait ce
qu'est vraiment dans le temps long alors
faut savoir le faire dans le ferroviaire
mais honnêtement quand j'en vois
bordeaux toulouse etc je pense que le
pot qu'il est un peu après c'est d'une
perspective qu'il faut pas écarter parce
que ça a beaucoup de sens mais vraiment
sur le temps long
sur centre val de loire écouter on
discute interview sur la rive à
converger tant mieux
voilà on est en train de regarder
comment convergent entre l'état la
région nous mêmes on essaie de créer les
conditions d'une sortie de négociation
que j'espère la plus proche possible et
tant mieux si nous arrivons à
converger sur les zones rurales telles
me suis mal exprimé je m'en excuse
d'ailleurs je n'en ai pas dit qu'ils
avaient une solution simple j'ai 17 ans
je vois là et je me suis moi même
positionné en 10 ans il faut être
correct là aussi il faut tant qu'on sera
pas capable de proposer des solutions
alternatives les gens n'auront pas le
choix et pendant la voiture faute
d'autres choses soient très claires j'ai
pas de solution miracle à ce stade ce
que je dis c'est que je la sncf est
prête à participer à des réflexions très
concrètes sur des territoires comment on
peut combiner des navettes comment vous
combinez certain nombre de choses voilà
je ne faut pas lâcher la faire mais je
suis conscient qu'au bout et que c'est
pas facile que bien évidemment les gens
n'ont pas le choix et prennent la
voiture j'ai joué moins de la famille
originaire de la campagne béarnaise je
vois très bien que dans le mode de vie
prennent la voiture à ça c'est sûr et il
peut pas faire autrement voilà donc la
question c'est ton qu'améliorer les jo
la sncf se retire des territoires bureau
des terrains séparés c'est monsieur prix
s'est pas laissé les régions la ssm 2,6
de plus des lignes régionales faut quand
même dire les choses mais dans les
bureaux de vente dans les points de
vente oui on me fera des propositions
dont vous avez un excellent rapport sur
les communes n'ont pas leurs arrêts
voilà je crois qu'on appelle temps mais
je la tue l'encours soyons réalistes
monsieur le sénateur en voyant les
choses en face un neuneu trompons pas
sur les enjeux vérité quand vous avez un
agent qui va trop habillée dans la
journée c'est pas durable
le salaire de cette personne n'est pas
durable quand il entre au billet vert à
1 vous fera des propositions faudrait
non mais vrai parce que vous et on sait
faire aussi le très bien mais tant mieux
faisons des propositions avant son
ensemble voyez ne rejetons pas
l'anathème sur les autres c'est pas
comme ça qu'on a encore avance sur les
autres france j'en ai parlé va plus tard
que ce matin que je vous dise oui la csn
n'est pas au rendez-vous le plan
d'action chez un peu moins sévère que
vous il produit ses effets on s'est
engagé pour janvier l'essor arrivée
janvier voilà deux après on les autres
sujets
on les évoque pas mais mais mais mais je
comprends la colère des usagers et là
dessus je comprends tout à fait là
encore là encore quand on creuse un peu
matériel ancien l'arrivée sur la gare du
nord etc etc les facteurs objectifs de
production sont pas faciles et entre
nous n'importe quel concurrent sera
soumis exactement même problème voilà
vous mettez n'importe quel concurrent
avec les mêmes matériels qui ont 40 ans
l'entrée à la gare du nord bon je leur
souhaite tout le sel du plaisir donc
mais ça ne suffit pas ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas travailler il faut
travailler mais il faut aussi voir les
choses en face sur la réalité des moyens
de production qui se confiait la sncf je
rappelle que ces moyens sont confiés par
la région la régionalisation est passée
par là donc la sncf elle a bon dos
parfois il faut là aussi faire la part
des choses mais mon esprit et
constructif mon esprit de prendre un
engagement devant vous comme je lé fais
devant les élus les eaux france
d'améliorer la situation par des mesures
de renfort exceptionnel vous avez pas
est en marche et on n'en est pas loin on
fait des renforts de matériel ont fait
des renforts de personnel on est à la
manoeuvre après ça ne se terminera que
l'ours qui effectivement les usagers
pourront constater que ça va mieux on
est bien d'accord avec vous donc je
prends le point il n'y a pas de problème
lyon turin s'est pas jean pierre
farandou qui fait lyon turin il avait en
pierre farandou il a fait son boulot il
a expliqué que c'était une bonne chose
que je soupçonnais le projet la décision
d et hier d'accès goto le gouvernement
voilà donc c'est pas jean pierre
farandou qui décide les infrastructures
ça fait partie de la clarification des
rôles que j'évoquais ce n'est plus la
sncf qui décide la construction des
lignes elle fait les lignes qu'on lui
demande de construire à partir des
financements qu'on lui amène c'est ça la
sncf d'aujourd'hui voilà donc
fall clarifie par contre j'espère que ma
position a été entendu je crois que
c'est le cas je me suis affiché comme
très favorable à ce cet équipement qui
là encore est copain est cohérent avec
le foie ne le foie de marchandises
supposera bien qu'on est l'itinéraire de
frais de nouveau sinon on sera à nouveau
limitée par les infrastructures
sur les petites lignes norge là aussi
j'ai pas de payer pas des formations
particulièrement mal à moi je ce que je
sais mais vous le savez moi comme moi
c'est que ça a été rappelé dare par le
ministre des transports le premier
ministre le gouvernement a sidi
l'appareil a parlé de 6 je pense c'est
un peu il va pas tarder à être huit ou
neuf je pense le gouvernement va signer
depuis un an c'est une démarche n'a été
entreprise irena des conventions avec la
plupart des régions pas tout mais
presque dans ces conventions il ya des
cofinancements entre l'état et la région
a c'est un processus haddock qui n'est
pas du cpr c'est un processus haddock
qui permet d'envisager effectivement le
financement de la régénération de
certaines petites villes voilà c'est en
cours là encore je le redis à la
position la ccf on est bien sûr très
favorable au développement des piles
ligne à paille à pattaya pas de doute là
dessus la régénération se fera quand les
conventions de financement seront sont
établis et là dessus ensuite ensuite la
région verra quel plan de services elle
veut déployer sur c'est sur ces lignes
voilà faudrait prendre les choses dans
l'ordre recherche et développement ce
que je peux vous dire c'est qu'à
l'initiative de la sncf pour le coup
nous sommes en train de travailler sur
un très léger qui est un concept en fin
d'exploitation moins coûteuse à la fois
sur l'infrastructure comme sur le
matériel roulant qui pourrait être
adapté aux parties les moins denses du
territoire avec des recherches
d'économies de 30 à 50 % quand même
thème considérable voilà on fait ça avec
les industriels ont fait ça dans le
programme d'investissement le pays à 4
ha qui est qui qui est en train d'être
finalisé donc je pense que c'est aussi
la vision qu'il faut avoir pour
accompagner le développement souhaité
par les régions c'est être capable que
l'industrie invente le chemin de fer
tout aussi confortable pour les
passagers mais beaucoup moins coûteux
pour la collectivité je pense que cet
objectif doit être retenue
voilà je peux dire en réponse rapide aux
questions pertinentes de mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs merci je vais
donner la parole à madame préville
et puis à monsieur louis jean de nicolay
à l'issue monsieur houlgate bien
monsieur fernique merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président farandou
alors je vais d'abord vous interrogez
enfin vous vous faire part du ressenti
puisqu'on peut ne sais pas s'il faut
l'appeler comme ça d'un territoire qui
est le bien qui est un territoire très
rural le département du lot donc avec
des remontées de des associations
d'usagers qui donc faut remonter que
certains trains de nuit pourrait
s'arrêter un petit peu plus dans le lot
je pense que ça ne devrait pas poser de
problème mais vous me le dire et
notamment à gourdon souillac cahors
puisque c'est l'objectif de ces trains
ce n'est pas d'aller très vite mais au
contraire peut-être de bien desservir le
territoire
ensuite parce que le transport
ferroviaire doit jouer un rôle central
dans la transition écologique et que
pour faire revenir les usagers ou les
garder il serait nécessaire de ne pas
délaisser ces territoires ruraux parce
qu'on se sent déjà à bien des égards un
peu en dehors de tout et notamment et je
vais vous parler là maintenant
concurrence enfin ouverture à la
concurrence parce que on a sur mon
territoire vous le savez une société
coopérative d'intérêt collectif qui
s'est créé et j'ai des questions à vous
poser à ce sujet
quelle est votre perception vis-à-vis
des initiatives comme celle de la
coopérative rail cup qui souhaitent
s'inscrire en complémentarité avec
l'offre de la sncf en rouvrant des
services ferroviaires là où la sncf
n'opère plus
envisagez-vous des synergies comme j'ai
dit des complémentarités entre les
offres sncf voyageurs et l'offre
proposée par rail coop parce
qu'effectivement cette ouverture à la
concurrence
qui a été voté comme vous l'avez rappelé
en 2018 peine quand même à se mettre en
place des nouveaux entrants fer ont fait
part publiquement de leur difficulté
d'accès au réseau français alors vous
avez dit tout à l'heure pour ce qui
concerne les sillons c'est parce qu'il
n'avait pas connaissance qu'il fallait
demander bien avant bon est-ce que c'est
ce sont les seuls sujets qu'elle quelle
est votre perception de des difficultés
éventuelles de sncf réseau a donné plus
de six ont notamment pour le fret et le
train de nuit et je veux quand même
puisque vous avez évoqué les territoires
ruraux vous dire que moi j'étais à
l'inauguration de la première ligne de
fret capdenac toulouse saint jory et
qu'il y avait un enthousiasme est
vraiment très fort parce que c'est une
société qui voit là et coopératives des
élus et de tous les citoyens du
territoire et je pense que c'est une
voie que vous devez entendre voilà merci
et monsieur louis jean de nicolay
merci
oui monsieur le président merci beaucoup
de questions beaucoup de réponses ont
été données à l'entendre les questions
je vais être donc assez rapide puis je
laisserais mon collègue guillaume
chollet parler des conventions desserte
moi j'ai deux questions premièrement
donc l'électrification sur l'ensemble
des lignes puisque qu'en est-il de
l'hydrogène aujourd'hui pour la sncf et
deuxièmement vous avez d'abord
deuxièmement je vais féliciter ou
remercier la sncf pour l'amélioration
des gars ya quand même eu un gros
travail de fait simplement on cherche
toujours les toilettes mais ça c'est un
autre problème
on s'est toujours caché dans un petit
coin et est un peu perdu et quand on
prend de l'âge en a besoin voilà et puis
surtout je voudrais d'avoir sur sur les
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure d'être
allégée de travail vient du ciel je
crois quand même qu'à ce moment il faut
mettre des dates butoirs un petit peu
parce que pour les pas que tous les cinq
ans du dixième au flat à trouver des
améliorations pour les trains faire
qu'il soit plus léger pour que consommer
moins avoir des dessertes peut-être plus
fréquentes parce que ça sera plus facile
pour peut-être plus automatisés et puis
le dernier point sur la halle c'est sur
la ligne alençon le mans tours où est-ce
qu'on en est sûre
la restructuration en fait de cette
ligne pour pour l'avenir est ce que est
ce que c'est bien décidés organisée
puisqu'elle est reprise par la sncf
merci chers collègues je vais donner la
parole à monsieur houlgate merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
président directeur général je vous
parlerai pas des trains normands je vous
renvoie donc à l'interview donnée par
hervé morin président de la région
normandie dans la besace et qu'au final
qui se pose la question de savoir si un
pilote dans le train sncf
je vais vous parler de deux de la dette
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire à peu
près quelle est la date prévisible à la
fin de l'exercice de 2021 et puis donc
pour pour retrouver des liquidités donc
la sncf s'est engagée dans une cession
d'actif ça a été le cas de dénis revoit
donc céder donc en octobre dernier dont
la finalisation est arrivé en octobre
dernier donc c'était une filiale de
location de wagons fret de conteneurs
est ce qu'il y à d'autres projets de
cessions en cours on parle de da qui
aime on parle d fia et puis également en
termes d'opportunités avec la sncf
possède de nombreuses emprises foncières
ça peut être des anciennes gares de
triage ça peut être des lieux qui
étaient des lieux non utilisé maintenant
pour de guerre de marchandises mais
aussi on le voit très bien de ce qu'on
peut rappeler des voix surnuméraires
dans les gares qui sont plus utilisés
qui sont à l'heure actuelle envahi par
les odeurs les élus notamment avec le
zéro artificialisation net recherche des
opportunités foncières
et pour pouvoir construire or il est
extrêmement difficile d'avoir un
interlocuteur et de la fluidité dans les
relations français avec la sncf il faut
des années on nous dit que les friches
on sait pas qui elles appartiennent et
appartiennent à la sernam qui n'existe
plus et ainsi de suite donc est ce que
vous comptez oui ou non flux unifier un
peu cet aspect qui représente
véritablement un enjeu déterminant pour
les élus notamment dans le cadre de la
production de logements nécessaires
merci et réaliste oui je vais donner pas
voilà monsieur chernick puis à monsieur
chevrollier monsieur gilles et à vendre
bien par le président pour répondre
merci président monsieur le président au
sujet du du volet transport et
ferroviaires de l'accord de coalition
gouvernementale allemand il ya une
eurodéputée cac a déclaré je cite il
s'agit pas seulement de se fixer de
jolis objectif pour 2030 mais il faut
livrer des résultats des résultats
sectoriels dans les différents domaines
évidemment c'est une réflexion qui est
transposable de notre côté du rhin vous
l'avez largement évoquée sur l'état du
réseau sa modernisation le coût d'accès
au réseau sur le fret ferroviaire les
trains voyageurs
particulier les trains de nuit alors sur
l'état du réseau et les perspectives
d'amélioration effectivement là la
comparaison avec la suisse est cruelle
pour le fret mon collègue chacun a parlé
d'un quant à sion au mieux on parle
d'une relance en demi teinte or vous
venez de le dire on peut pas y aller à
moitié en tout cas on se sent pas en
position de pouvoir combler à terme le
net décalage par exemple par exemple
avec l'allemagne sur les trains de nuit
si la tendance à leur renouveau et là on
est quand même bien loin du modèle
autrichien avec leurs investissements
très conséquents sur leurs rames
notamment pour vous je crois avoir
compris que c'est plutôt une niche je
pense qu'on a pourtant avec les trains
nuit un outil pour la bascule de
l'aérien vers le ferroviaire pour les
trajets européens de moins de 1500 km un
autre outil ce serait le juste cool
l'aérien vous avez eu quelques mots
récemment là dessus alors je suis
sénateur du bas-rhin l'objectif est de
faire de strasbourg une gare pivot ancré
au réseau allemand est bien connecté à
terme à francfort et à castres où les
échanges des élus locaux avec la sncf là
dessus sont plutôt décevants ils n'ont
pas l'impression de voir une stratégie
qui se construit donc quelle est la
détermination réelle de la sncf a mené
cette mutation qui est pas une question
locale il s'agit d'un enjeu essentiel
pour notre capitale parlementaire
européenne
merci chers collègues messieurs
chevrollier
merci monsieur le président c'est le
présent phares on nous avait indiqué
qu'il était important d'écouter les
territoires bonjour à revenir sur la
relation avec les collectivités locales
notamment le cadre du comité de suivi
des dessertes de la ligne lgv ouest on
convient d'avoir l'information sur une
bonne nouvelle sur le maintien du niveau
de desserte notamment de la gare de
laval avec les huit tgv aller retour ce
qui est capital pour le territoire pour
son attractivité d'avoir cette stabilité
de dessertes mais pourquoi refuser le
renouvellement de la convention de
desserte qui se termine en 2022 une
relation de confiance ça se construit
avec des conventions juridiques du mans
a signé
vous avez également évoqué la nécessité
d'inventer des solutions dans les
territoires voudrais évoquer une
solution qui est à valoriser accompagné
c'est là dans le cadre du fret
ferroviaire c'est là la solution voutré
double fret qui permettra de relier une
carrière de pierre importante dans mon
département à l'île de france avec cette
solution d'envoyer des matériaux de
pierres dans l'île de france est de
ramener du remblai
l'île de france notamment avec les
travaux du grand paris donc c'était une
solution accompagner cette solution donc
vous goûterez double fred qui me semble
est à valoriser et à mettre en avant
dans leur tour la nécessité du fret dont
on parle beaucoup mais qu'il faut
réhabiliter et enfin vous avez parlé
d'environnement lors de votre dernier
passage vous avez interrogé on venait de
légiférer sur une proposition de loi sur
la réduction de l'empreinte
environnementale du numérique vous nous
aviez indiqué que vous étiez mobilisé
sur le sujet ce que à ce jour vous
pouvez vous faire un bilan de votre
engagement sur cette réduction de
l'empreinte environnementale du
numérique au sein du groupe sncf merci
collègue monsieur merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président
directeur général l'année dernière
vous ne faisiez un état des lieux et
vous remettiez en perspective les
objectifs louables de la loi l'homme et
notamment le fait de réinvestir sur les
petites lignes les transports du
quotidien aujourd'hui un nouveau
paradigme ne semble se mettre en place
puisqu'on en relance les lignes de la
grande vitesse et ça interroge
effectivement fortement ses interroge
autant plus fortement que la relance de
ces lignes lgv se situe aussi dans un
nouveau contexte un nouveau paradigme de
crise énergétique et en terme de
prospective ça interroge sur de quelle
manière on va accompagner globalement
avec l'ensemble des acteurs que ça soit
les régions les métropoles mais la sncf
justement comment va accompagner la
montée en puissance des transports du
quotidien alors est-ce que tout est
compatible est-ce que nous pouvons tous
faire sur la lgv la relance de la lgv
bordeaux toulouse et bordeaux dax
puisque les deux sont intimement liés
elles sont intimement liés parce que si
on va voir du financement européen il
faut faire bordeaux dax il faut faire
bordeaux dax avec un bouchon connu de
toute façon pour aller effectivement
vers l'espagne et pour l'instant il n'y
a aucune solution aucune solution donc
on lance deux grands projets
14,3 milliards d'euros qui engage
l'ensemble des collectivités une grande
partie des collectivités territoriales
puisqu'il ya quelques refus alors qu'en
termes de perspectives on voit bien
qu'il n'y ait même pas en capacité de
débouchés à l'heure actuelle de toute
évidence ces financements vauban et au
moins en partie une partie des
financements qui pourront être alloués
sur les transports du quotidien et
nouveau paradigme sncf réseau va devoir
participer donc là sur l'assiette
financière il est prévu une
participation des ccf réseau ce qui
n'était pas privé jusqu'à maintenant si
vous pouvez nous apporter des précisions
autre précision 4,1 milliards sont
prévus théoriquement uniquement sur
bordeaux toulouse à ce jour je ne sais
pas comment ils sont inscrits si vous
avez des informations sur l'inscription
de l'engagement gouvernemental des 4,1
milliards d'euros je suis preneur parce
que pour l'instant c'est complètement
effectivement des bulles et pourtant il
y a des engagements politiques
particulièrement fort puisque le premier
ministre a relancé ce dossier n'y voyez
vous pas quand même quelque part une
démarche assez contradictoire par
rapport à l'ensemble des enjeux que vous
avez pu souligner à la fois le réseau la
modernisation etc etc bref on est rentré
dans une période où on veut tout faire
est ce que vous vous pensez vraiment que
tout ça est réaliste
merci je vais donner la parole aux
prises un fardeau pour rassurer mes
collègues il reste cinq demandes de
parole vous aurez tous et toutes la
parole mais je n'ai mis dans l'ordre de
demandes
merci à chaque fois la pédagogie est
nécessaire mais je la fais bien
volontiers les trains de nuit que vous
évoquez s'en font partie les trains
d'équilibré du territoire dont
l'autorité c'est l'état c'est l'état qui
dit où ça s'arrête voilà donc goto
l'état oui voilà nous on vous rend
s'arrête là où on nous dit de s'arrêter
par ailleurs sur les territoires en
l'euro en europe et la thématique oui il
faut il ya du travail
on est prêt je le redis à s'inscrire
dans comment capillarité on peut on peut
ramener de l'offre est ramené au travers
emmenés dans les gares on a 70 % des
français qui habitent à moins de 5 km
d'une gare et 90% des français qui
habitent à moins de 10 kilomètres d'une
gare dans les 5 km et 10 km qui sont
clés alors dans la gare faut trouver des
trains bien sûr mais déjà cessé km et 10
km ans excellent jeu ouais c'est pas la
même chose c'est kilomètres et des
kilomètres à ccc voilà donc c'est ça il
faut que sert qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
travailler on a on a du boulot mais mais
on a de bons rails coop écoutez moi je
leur en veux pas de mal à les rails coop
juillet ils ont jeté certaine sympathie
pour les créateurs de rail cup
après est prêt il découvre le chemin de
fer voilà bon je vais le faire c'est un
métier ça fait quarante et un ans je le
fais donc je peux leur prétention de
connaître le découvre les sillons les
engins la maintenance et conducteurs
très bien écouter ces sympathiques moi
je le redis bien je suis comme vous je
les ressens pas comme des concurrents
photo il se met plutôt dans les trous
voilà voilà ça ne se faisait pas donc
voila mais c'est pas qui me gêne mais
mais ils ont une iso il sondera cours
d'apprentissage comme on dit ils sont
dans la courbe d'apprentissage du
ferroviaire on leur souhaite de la de la
franchit rapidement voilà pour que pour
la pérennité de la coopérative parce que
on a beau être une coopérative on est
rattrapé par les exercices comptables
tôt ou tard voilà donc on leur souhaite
ne pas avoir embarqué tous les tous les
conquérants dans une aventure économique
qui pourrait s'avérer compliquée donc il
faut vite qu'ils arrivent à prendre la
maîtrise technique de lors de leurs
opérations
sur
les réseaux fret renuy bon ça c'est
directement lié au pas les mêmes
capacités donc là on en revient sujet
central vous avez raison le x 2 mais
même le nom mentation qui serait pas
photo et compliqué le réseau ferroviaire
il est plein en gros enfin nos camps les
endroits danse donc il faut de la
capacité le problème des trains de fret
c'est qu'ils sont unis circulent peu le
jour beaucoup la nuit la nuit ya les
travaux moralité ils ont du mal à passer
donc un terrain pas beaucoup ça va si on
voulait en faire davantage en aurait un
problème donc effectivement vous avez
raison de dire il ya un vrai sujet de
stratégie ferroviaire pour le pour le
pour le réseau vous allez examiner
bientôt le contrat de performance c'est
ce qu'a dit le président pour moi le
contrat de performance il traite les
hypothèses de volume de 2018 qui était
un espèce de continuité comme comme la
croissance qu en gros le trafic
ferroviaire évolué comme le pib ça
marche si on a une ambition supérieur je
pense le contrat de performance n'est
pas tout à fait à la hauteur il faudrait
inventer autre chose ça on en revient
aux débats de fond qu'on a pu évoquer
avec vous
électrification des lignes effectivement
c'est pas forcément l'alpha et l'oméga -
comme vous je crois à l'hydrogène je
pense que l'hydrogène peut être une
solution très intéressante pour éviter
d'électrifier les lignes justement
l'objectif on le rappelle zéro émission
dès 2050 pour plus de diesel pour la
sncf et les régions les plus d'envié
zèle entre parenthèses les régions
devront faire des choix dans 2030-2035
les parcs régionaux actuels vont arriver
pour le coup en fin de vie il faudra
donc commander de nouveaux parcs et là
l'enjeu hydrogène va être là il faut
absolument que l'industrie non seulement
l'industrie du matériel roulant elle
sera prête mais la vraie question on la
connaît tous et comme on est capable de
fabriquer beaucoup d'électricité y
reviennent beaucoup d'îles reviennent
pardon à des prix raisonnables et ils
reviennent vers bien sûr ça aujourd'hui
c'est pas traiter ça c'est ça qui doit
donc c'est ça l'enjeu majeur comment on
est capable de disposer de beaucoup de
ressources en hydrogène à des prix
raisonnables déployés sur le territoire
ça l'enjeu industriel
et le stocker et c est ok on est à peu
près mais c'est la production un coût
raisonnable ça c'est un challenge les
gars merci pour les commentaires en fait
on a une action vigoureuse sur les gars
on veut pas lancer laisser tomber les
gars même les petits gars on s'intéresse
à toutes les gares on a une nouvelle
directrice des gars qui est formidable
déjà un programme il une guerre elle est
en train d'en préparer un autre on veut
vraiment travailler pour le coup dans
les petites gares avec les maires avec
les collectivités locales pour redonner
de la vie dans les gars qui fait écho
aux petits débats qu'on a eu comment re
met de la vie dans les gares 7 bis dans
les gares pouvoir permettre de des
billets elop ça se remarque
effectivement vous avez raison il faut
mettre le paquet sur les gars avec les
territoires avec un financement régional
font reconnaître c'est souvent les
régions qui financent mais la sncf peut
accompagner en tout cas là on vit voilà
elle en a envie
/
le progrès alors très léger industrielle
soit on est en train de bourrer bâtir le
programme de recherche donc faut dire
qu'il se passe on n'est pas encore
passée à la phase industrielle mais il y
aura des dates du rader da sur l'issue
de la recherche et le début de la mise
en production industrielle / à lens
allant sur le mans tours c'est il ya
plusieurs régions qui sont concernés ce
qu'il fait partie un peu de la
difficulté d'ailleurs la solution de
cible c'est l'hydrogène je crois que
c'est un marchand avec je sais que là la
région pays de la loire veut veut mettre
des rames à hydrogène sur cette ligne
voilà après j'ai pas le détail on pourra
peut-être vous renseigner et avec plus
de précision
le maire with me suivre et d'intervenir
sur ce point puisque effectivement la
région pays de la loire au travers d'une
entreprise qui s'appelle live qui est
implantée à bouin qui produit
d'hydrogène vert à partir de diderot
d'éoliennes et de l'eau de mer
vient de signer d'ailleurs je vous en
informe poser la faux avec la 2 vannes
pour fournir de l'hydrogène vers la 2
vannes qui travaillent sur l'hydrogène
depuis avec une expérimentation depuis
plus de quatre ans maintenant donc voilà
c'est une info c'est possible sur le
plan industriel
l'entreprise est prête à la dimension
aujourd'hui kate internationale donc si
vous souhaitez vous en rapprocher je
peux faire le médiateur si vous le
souhaitez je crois qu'on l'a déjà les
cours donnés c'était entendre une en
tout cas merci beaucoup ça va avec la
l'impulsion donnée par la région sur
cette ligne là
sur la dette tac tac tac bons airs mais
va vous avez comme moi
regarder la voix la cession des ravers
ont la fièvre de la crise n'y aurait pas
eu la crise n'aurait pas rendu armé va
on a fait notre rôle qui toujours
difficile quand vous êtes patron d'un
groupe vous n'avez pas à vendre des
sociétés surtout quand elles marchent
bien mais comme elle marche bien elle va
de l'argent voilà y'a pas de mystère
voilà comment on avait besoin d'argent
parce que le coût qui nous a beaucoup
fait mal fait on est passé vite mais
faut bien se rendre compte de l'impact
économique majeur du coc vide donc hissé
qui a fini par se voir sur la dette
notre dette a augmenté à cause du coït
quand la dette augmente d'un où
l'actionnaire vous mais un peu d'argent
mais il est remis de l'argent mais pour
les travaux il a pas mis sur le bilan il
a mis pour régénérer les travaux et donc
sur le bilan on a fait une session voilà
donc c'est ça la raison est-ce qu'elle
ad'autres écouter on peut faire des
revenus de portefeuille mais pour le
moment il ya rien de décidé
voilà on verra si les opportunités ou
pas dans les dents les dans l'est dans
les mois qui viennent les emprises
ferroviaires on y travaille on a une
nouvelle directrice de l'immobilier qui
vient d'ailleurs des collectivités donc
elle à cette sensibilité que vous
évoquez après peut être pour avoir
moi-même suivi quelques dossiers c'est
objectivement pas simple parce que ça il
ya tout un arsenal de procédures de
qu'on appelle ça de mutabilité comment
des classes une installation ferroviaire
pour la rendre ses cibles c'est plus
simple que ça il ya toujours un bout
d'installation dessus on écoute toujours
avec joie et bonheur qui a un bout de
deux transformateurs de câbles qui
passent enfin voilà s'est jamais aussi
simple que ça en a l'air pour autant
comme vous je souhaite que les choses se
fassent la meilleure plus rapide
possible la plus fluide possible et la
plus grande transparence possible et là
on voit bien que le temps la ccs n'est
pas le temps des élus en internement
d'art et un maire qui arrivent il veut
faire son projet rapidement il nous faut
qu'on arrive à tenir la cadence pour lui
dire très vite qu'est ce qui est
possible qu est ce qui n'est pas parce
que parfois ça peut être une partie qui
est possible par le voilà donc en tout
cas c'est un sujet qui est pointée et
sur lequel nous essayons de progresser
alors sur les trains de nuit les trains
de nuit c'est un peu la même réponse je
les dis je crois que l'évoqué tout à
l'heure
c'est l'état qui doit prendre la main
les traîne aujourd'hui la sncf n'a plus
le matériel roulant pour développer les
traits nuit on l'a pas on a même rénové
des très vieux matériel pour ouvrir les
lignes qu'on nous a demandé de nous et
on la fait bien volontiers et là encore
l'état a joué le jeu puisque à travers
le plan de relance il nous a donné
l'argent pour le faire il ya pas de
problème si on veut aller plus loin
c'est une vision qui appartient à l'état
parce que leur rentabilité n'est pas
assurée et nous pensons que n'importe
quel opérateur même privé en tout cas ça
aura du mal à justifier l'investissement
en capital roulant les recettes peuvent
payer les coûts les coûts de
fonctionnement mais le capital roulant
nécessaire aussi bien les locomotives
que les rames ça ça passe pas donc
faudra l'investissement détail c'est ce
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure je crois
en réponse à une question mais moi sur
le fond comme vous je serai ravi qu'ils
aient calé trény qui roule en europe 1
ça me on va commencer quand même enfin
il ya l'espace des choses viennent paris
cette année il ya un berlin paris qui se
profile fin 2023 on a fait une alliance
avec les autrichiens qui sont plutôt en
avance là-dessus les allemands les
suisses et nous voilà ce bloc là on
irrigue femmes à l'europe et à partir de
là on peut quand même développé dans les
show devant se faire mais si on veut
passer la surmultipliée cela supposera
une décision claire et financé de l'état
pour la pour le pour le matériel roulant
alors sur la valve est tant mieux si les
choses s'arrangent écoutez la période du
kobe nous à nous avons fait ensemble
quand on est prudent dans les
engagements de long terme on a appris à
nos dépens qu'il faut et se passer des
choses écouter les trains sont là tant
mieux on souhaite à vous l'avez senti
peut-être d'ailleurs que c'est un sujet
on souhaite avoir une certaine ne pas
être emprisonnée on souhaite avant une
certaine liberté de manoeuvre en
fonction des événements l'expérience
récente nous a appris que c'était une
bonne chose parce qu'il pourrait se
passer des choses qu'on n'avait pas
forcément prévu
solution dans les territoires on a tant
mieux oui je sais très bonne idée donc
moi je te fais preneur de 10 des venant
des territoires pour créer desserte fret
voilà qui fonctionne pas de problème sur
le numérique j'ai pas la réponse à votre
question je préfère être franc donc on
vous répondra avait après année ont pris
le temps de collationner l'information
que vous avez demandé
je ne sais pas exactement vous dire où
en année donnons notre volonté de
réduire l'empreinte l'empreinte carbone
de l'eau de l'eau et forme numérique
communication alors là dessus si ça
c'est un sujet de fond donc il arrive
maintenant ou là on l'a déjà effleuré
mois bref deux choses l'une on en
revient finalement au sujet de fond
qu'on a déjà évoqué qu'est ce qu'on va
faire pour de vrai si l'ambition que
nous avons évoquées passe à m'en donner
par par des moyens d'argent public
constant et ceux d'avant ça marchera pas
parce qu'on va déshabiller pierre pour
habiller paul et ça c'est ce qu'on a
fait au fond pendant des décennies qui
rendent la frustration chez pierre ou
chez paul donc la solution c'est bien de
trouver des recettes nouvelles si un ça
ne marchera pas il faut que ensemble les
parlementaires la classe politique à la
sncf et tous ceux qui voudront
participer au débat on arrive à
augmenter les recettes nouvelles les
deux exemples que je donne les suisses
pourquoi ça marche en suisse on serait
plus bête les français que les suisses
parce que depuis des décennies ils ont
un fonds de financement de tours travaux
ferroviaires qu'on a pas nous autre
exemple beaucoup plus près de chez nous
la sgp société du grand paris 100 km de
métro l'exécutif de l'époque fait passer
une loi au parlement qui créent les
instruments fiscaux pour dégénérer 35
milliards qui est le coût du projet ça
roule mon collègue la ngp il a plus de
problème d'argent il a des problèmes et
rideaux agit là des problèmes mais il a
plus de problème d'argent moi j'en rêve
en grève si on me fait la ngp du
ferroviaire moi je suis absolument ravi
voilà mais c'est autour de ça que ça se
passe et honnêtement on a trouvé 35
milliards d'euros pour faire 100 km de
métro automatique est-ce que ça serait
choquant de trouver 35 milliards d'euros
pour rénover le système ferroviaire
français la question vaut est ce que les
enjeux d'intérêt général sont moins
équivalent à envahir voilà en tout cas
le débat je pense il faut le lancer et
réfléchir aux la technicalité ensuite
budgétaire qu'il faudra qu'il faudra
trouver en tout cas moi je trouve que
les une perspective qui est atteignable
au passage sa règle les problèmes des
ddd dépit lynn pascoe en termes de
gouvernance on avait un fond comme ça
imaginons en font bien sûr que les
régions seront encore gouvernance de ce
fonds bien évidemment c'est pas la seule
sncf qui va gouverner ce fonds l'etat
sera là les régions seront là les
territoires seront là et pour mettre
pour prioriser ordonné trouver les
plannings et ça résout les questions que
les questions que vous avez soulevés y
compris sur les petits digne mais ya pas
de mystère il faut générer la ressource
sinon là pour le court on sera à nouveau
affaire va faire du bonneteau d'un
projet à l'autre d'un dossier à l'autre
et moi je n'ai pas envie personnellement
vous savez moi à mon âge
voilà j'ai envie que les choses soient
claires voilà j'ai passé l'âge de la
confusion et des hésitations je
préférerais que les choses soient net et
franchement s'ils sont fait jouer ses
sont favorables au ferroviaire ça
m'irait très bien voilà donc je pense
que c'est le nerf de la guerre comme
d'habitude je ne surprendrai pas des
gens d'expérience comme vous en vous le
disant voilà
donc il reste six demandes de parole
s'il y en a d'autres qui veulent alors
ici demandé par rome alain perreault
monsieur calvet mesdames varaillas ce
monsieur dantec madame de six ans que
monsieur guéret s'il y en a d'autres je
crois que ce sera sans moi je à quoi
j'ai pas répondu excuse moi
à oui
oui
j'ai répondu j'ai répondu j'ai répondu
le fond si on n'arrive pas à générer oui
bien sûr il faut tout financier sinon on
n'est pas cohérent il faut pas opposer
l'un à l'autre la même manière que sur
la lgv bordeaux-toulouse que je soutiens
jeu l'associent à au sud de bordeaux et
au nord de toulouse bien évidemment vous
mais des capacités quand vous habitez
langon qu'aviez vous n'arrivez plus à
rentrer dans bordeaux ni en voiture ni
en train comment on fait en plus avec la
coved les gens quitter l'agglomération
bordelaise pour venir vivre justement
dans les petites villes le train la
seule solution est le ter doit venir le
rer en erreur métropolitaine dans les
grandes agglomérations celui qui trouve
une autre solution il a qu'à me le dire
c'est la seule solution donc faut la
mettre en oeuvre donc il faut de
l'argent on en revient inexorablement à
la capacité et ton cas pas dans ce pays
de trouver les sommes d'argent
nécessaires à remplir les besoins des
populations parce que l'alarmé sur les
besoins des populations voilà c'est la
question que je pose après c'est le
sujet de priorité c'est un sujet mais je
pense que c'est ça le bon niveau du
débat c'est celui là en fait parce que
c'est la mère des batailles à partir de
là nous aurons lyon éclairer bien des
sujets que nous avons évoqué aujourd'hui
merci mais mme perreault oui alors
président je vais vous dire grand test
et ligne 4 ça c'est catastrophique et
vous le savez je pense que vous avez
reçu le maximum de courrier là dessus
donc c'est vrai que vous avez fait une
réponse à mon voisin je pense que je
vais avoir la même mais très sincèrement
je pense qu'au niveau des informations
sur les retards et les annulations ça
devrait être un petit peu plus complet
vous voyez ça permettrait aux
aux voyageurs de s'organiser nettement
mieux et les vous avez une suppression
enfin une annulation au départ de la
gare de l'est ça c'est catastrophique
parce qu'il n'y a aucune information
les gens quand il y à un train qui est
disponible tout le monde s'engouffre
dedans vous avez le suivant qui étaient
dix minutes avec personne dedans je les
prie si nous étions dix dans un ter
double pour aller sur mulhouse c'est
tout ce que nous étions alors que le
train précédent était bondée donc là il
manque de l'information c'est tout pour
le reste j'ai eu la réponse avec mon
voisin merci
merci
messieurs calvet oui monsieur le
président monsieur le président je
souhaite vous interroger sur deux points
le premier c'est le projet de la ligne
nouvelle montpellier perpignan
qui a été à l'époque j'étais rapporteur
à l'assemblée nationale en 1995 pour mon
groupe du tronçon binational filière
perpignan et depuis le tas est bien long
ce chaînon manquant dans cette ligne
madrid barcelone paris
nous ridiculisent par rapport à
l'espagne parce que nous étions la porte
de france nous sommes une enclave
nouvelle maintenant et j'ai bien vu que
la loi l'homme du 24 décembre 2019
considéré comme ce projet comme
prioritaires et que les études avaient
été engagées les travaux ont été
commandés notamment sur la partie
montpellier béziers mais nous savons que
il a été jugé prioritaire depuis toutes
ces années par tous les gouvernements
juste avant les élections et donc je
voulais savoir si nous aurions une
chance de pouvoir pour ses 140
kilomètres manquants
pouvoir avoir une accélération de ce
processus car pour l'instant et on aura
mis si tout se passe bien cinquante ans
pour faire à 140 kilomètres de lignes et
donc je trouve que ce n'est pas une
dynamique extraordinaire par rapport à
l'espagne que nous avons donné même si
les espagnols en faisant leur tgv ont eu
quelques soucis merveille il fonctionne
et nous nous sommes toujours au même
point depuis 1995
deuxième question je voulais avoir un
peu quelle était la perspective de fret
du fret au niveau de la sncf et en
particulier le premier ministre est venu
relancer la ligne de fret perpignan
régis si vous avez un bilan quelque
chose pour savoir où on en est
fonctionnel refonctionne depuis pas
longtemps mais en fait j'aurais voulu
savoir quoi la merci
si la promesse avant les élections tu
l'auras
madame varaillas
oui monsieur le président mon jeu je
voudrais vous dire d'abord que je note
avec satisfaction votre volonté d'être
au plus près des territoires et du
personnel dans le cadre de cette
transition que notamment l'ouverture à
la concurrence ceci étant dit plus
qu'une question il ya la question des
salaires mais il ya la question des
conditions de travail également la
charge vous connaissez les je pense le
technicentre de périgueux dans le
département de la dordogne vous êtes
venus le visiter lettre vous savez que
aujourd'hui les travaux d'aménagement
des voitures couchettes avance avec g
beaucoup de difficultés par manque de
personnel formé et de pièces également
la précarité se renforce aussi notre le
personnel avec le recrutement important
d'intérimaires je crois qu'il y en a un
plus de 80 qui ont été recrutés non
formés et ses intérimaires forcément ce
n'est de pas à mener correctement le
chantier
deux kilomètres plus loin aux ateliers
de la voie à chamiers alors que des
besoins en termes d'entretien sur
l'ensemble du territoire sont immenses
et nous l'avons dit a été dit ce matin
l'établissement qui comptait plus de 200
cheminots en 2000 n'en compte plus que
76 et on peut dire que nous n'avons pas
de visibilité de charges au delà de
septembre 2022 sur cc c'est quelque
chose qui est inquiétant au regard des
besoins que l'on connaît sur l'ensemble
du territoire alors vous avez évoqué
également
la priorité donnée à l'amélioration
services en gare c'est vrai que les
agents d'escale et de vente des gares
dénonce manque de personnel évident les
postes ne sont pas tenus ou alors par
des personnels en cdd voire même des cdd
senior le service n'est pas rendu
correctement et c'est vrai que personnel
est en souffrance il faut le dire
comme
de la même manière en matière de
circulation et d'aiguillage ce manque de
personnel il a des conséquences directes
sur la circulation des princes comme on
est en plus sur une voie simple un agent
aiguilleurs qui n'est pas là c'est une
gare fermée ou un croisement qui ne se
fait pas voilà nos difficultés sur le
terrain
merci mais schirrhein tech oui merci
monsieur le président 1dans dans la
liste des litanies mais je ne vous
demande pas monsieur le président
obligatoirement une réponse précise je
pense que l'offre sur les lignes delà de
la bretagne sud entre nantes
et brest et entre nantes et rennes
correspond plus aujourd'hui à la demande
quand même beaucoup train où on reste
debout très très longtemps alors
j'espère que c'est pas lié à ce
découpage administratif dans tout le
monde sait ici à quel point je le
soutiens mais en tout cas là on est on a
une vraie question aujourd'hui sur
notamment sur la ligne quimper quimperlé
mai mais là dessus c'est juste pour vous
le signalez la question en fait je
reviens sur la question d'olivier chacun
au tout début
il a parlé d'un quant à sion par rapport
au développement du fret mal je vous ai
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention depuis
plus d'une heure vous avez été très
précis sur les nouvelles offres
voyageurs on sent là que la maison fait
preuve de beaucoup d'imagination
des trains plus lent et moins cher enfin
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de projets dans
les tuyaux
je n'ai pas entendu
quelle était la stratégie sur le fret
c'est à dire on croit qu'on partage
totalement le sentiment qu'il faut
absolument qu'une partie du fret
européen repas sur le rail est ce qu a
dit jacques fernique me semble important
sur le fait de savoir s'il le
volontarisme du nouveau gouvernement
allemand ne va pas mettre derrière
l'industrie allemande
en situation davantage concurrentielle
très très fort sur l'offre de fret
ferroviaire européen c'est là il ya un
volontarisme politique évident donc moi
mais ma question c'est vraiment de dire
puisqu'il nous reste peu de temps c'est
s'il ya trois grandes mesures à prendre
pour développer le fret ferroviaire en
france en investissement en service ces
lesquels parce que on a un peu de mal
nous derrière à relayer les priorités
sur le fred puisqu'on ne voit pas bien
en fait quelle est la vraie stratégie de
la sncf
merci chers collègues et madame de
civrac merci président oui monsieur le
président moi je voudrais revenir sur
le rapport de la cour des comptes du 20
avril dernier un rapport qui a été quand
même relativement sévères concernant la
sncf notamment gares et connexions sur
cette thématique là un certain nombre de
points positifs ont été relevées ici et
là depuis bien sûr mais les disparités
de services entre les gares le système
des redevances ou les transferts de
propriété sur les gardes locales sont
notamment pointés en fait par la
juridiction de façon aiguë donc moi j'ai
deux questions autour de cela malgré
effectivement un certain nombre de
points sur lesquels vous êtes revenu
quels sont aujourd'hui les
préconisations de la courbe que vous
avez déjà mises en oeuvre et quelle est
votre position sur la réforme des
redevances merci beaucoup
monsieur guéret oui mais c'est le
président d'abord merci pour votre
volontarisme à faire les choses
moi j'ai passé les 15 dernières années
ma vie à travailler avec vous au
quotidien deux exemples quand vous dites
le temps politique n'est pas le temps
ferroviaire c'est une réalité que nous
connaissons tous surtout quand on
conduit des projets avec vous néanmoins
c'est possible c'est à dire deux
exemples moi j'ai eu à travailler pour
avoir lancé projet de la rouverture lit
de la ligne chartres orléans j'ai eu à
travailler avec vous et la région sur
ces questions là on n'a pas rouvert
chantera les hommes en a rouvert
dimanche entre tour puisqu'on est robert
27 km de voies mais on a quand même mis
28 ans le faire donc oui c'est long mais
on y est arrivé deuxième chose
en charge du projet intermodal de
chartres depuis maintenant 17 ans
34 hectares de réaménagement autour du
plateau intermodal 15 hectares mutable
on a mis 13 ans a négocié les surfaces
foncières mais voilà nous y sommes
arrivés c'est fait alors cessé ses longs
et la difficulté c'est que sur des
projets comme cela la difficulté c'est
que la plupart des collectivités ne
dispose pas du temps nécessaire
politiquement pour les conduire puisque
le temps ferroviaire est extrêmement
longue la fin je voudrais quand même
dire que c'était chose possible tout
après une question de gouvernance et
puis surtout de veiller à avoir une
burette d'huile tous les jours pour
mettre de l'huile dans les rouages n'y
arrivent dont je voulais quand même vous
dire que c'était quand même quelque part
une note d'optimisme ce qu'il fallait
persévérer quant au modèle suisse que
vous avez cités je suis allé voir
effectivement plusieurs fois sur des
chantiers comme zurich comment les
suisses à bord de ces questions là il ya
effectivement des idées à prendre mais
ça on le sait depuis une cinquantaine
d'années donc voilà je n'apporte rien de
nouveau au système
merci chacun aime mais chez le président
4 effectivement je fais partie des
lignes lors ce moment les problèmes de
qualité de service s'est remonté au plus
haut niveau il ya des réunions
d'ailleurs qui sont prévues avec des
grands élus de la ligne voilà dans les
choses sont prises en main comme c'est
le cas sur le sureau de france et il ya
une vraie
intervention implication du niveau
national pour trouver des solutions sur
ces deux lignes ce que vous dites sur
l'information la saf et vous avez
entièrement raison enfin c'est quand
même très dommage de pas pouvoir capable
d'informer les gens que dix minutes
airplane train donc ça c'est quand même
des loupés d'informations retrouvez
thématique avait été soulevée par un
autre sénateur je crois sûr sûr sûr le
clairement sur os sur le puy de dôme
donc ça il faut vraiment qu'on arrive à
être capable d'informer les voyageurs
vous avez entièrement raison je ne peux
que kay d'accord avec vous le
montpellier perpignan bon là encore je
vais pas me défausser mais vous savez
que là on est en plein quand même dans
l'état qui doit battre la mesure sur
l'instruction et des décisions sur ces
lignes là j'ai compris que le prémice
était très attaché à ce que les choses
avancent dans les procédures notamment
avec un lancement record de l' enquête
d'utilité publique qui thil qui qui va
être fait je crois d'ici la fin de
l'année il tenait absolument à qu'elle
soit lancée elle va être lancé donc
voilà après c'est un long chemin mais en
tout cas il ya une volonté de de faire
avancer les choses et côté sncf réseau
on s'est mis en mesure d'être de tenir
cette c'est impératif de dates qui
étaient pas négligeable parce que c'est
un autre débat les procédures s'est pas
laissé de celles qui les fait un c'est
la loi les règlements elles sont très
très compliqué dans notre pays sans
parler des recours sans parler des
recours qui viennent en cours derrière
ralentir les travaux etc etc c'est un
vrai sujet bon on va pas l'ouvrir mais
on pourrait aussi discuté de ça le
perpignan régis écouté il marche bien je
suis ravi que l'heure c'est le
gouvernement l'a aussi qu'après
initiative parce que faut être clair le
gouvernement a créé les conditions
financières pour relancer ce train si
l'on ne nous mêmes on l'aurait pas fait
parce que ce très rôdée par des parents
talent il ya pas il ya passé de
marchandises voilà donc il ya une vraie
volonté le volontarisme politique comme
l'a dit le premier ministre pour
relancer ce train nous l'avons fait nous
avons rénové les wagons de la retrouver
voilà on a relancé ce train il c'est
conforme aux prévisions vous savez qu'il
ya c'est un chargeur principalement qui
a pris les capacités de ce train il
tient ici elle comptera qu'il avait pris
dont les choses se font on est aussi
même en train maintenant de travailler
sur le la deuxième partie de ce projet
qui est de faire une autoroute
ferroviaire entre le roussillon et l'île
de france on est en train d'ajuster le
meilleur le meilleur sion le meilleur
chemin pour le faire les choses se
déroulent comme ça a été dit et comme
cela était prévu
sur les seuls les points soulevés par
balle à la sénatrice qui doit
représenter la dordogne je suppose donc
on a parlé de périgueux et chamiers oui
vous avez raison faut être attentif au
sujet de formation au sujet de personnel
sur les sujets d'intérimaires moi j'ai
donné des orientations qui sont claires
moi je n'ai rien contre l'embauché
d'intérimaires après il faut que sa
paire cole dans les établissements mais
moi je peux vous dire qu'en ce qui me
concerne j'ai été très clair ça ne me
dérange pas quand comprennant contrat
sncf d intérim et au bout d'un moment
les connaît il faut y remplissent et ils
font bien le travail que le curseur sera
déplacé vers davantage de recrutement a
laissé ça me va bien je regarderai ce
qu'il faut faire sur périgueux mais je
vous je vous suis parfaitement sur ces
sujets là
sur bretagne sud on a quelques
connaisseurs dans la salle du réseau
régional breton c est aussi bien sûr à
travailler avec la région sur le fret
qui est quand même l'équipe et refait le
fond de votre question si la stratégie
on n'a pas eu l'occasion d'en parler
enfin vous avez trois segments dans le
fret le wagon isolé le combiné les très
massif le combiné ça pousse très fort
c'est laisser les containers les côtés
rc lens où le trafic mondial des
containers les bateaux même si en ce
moment c'est un peu déréglé tout ça là
pour le coup il ya des systèmes qui
existent des dalles à pinces a aussi
déjà depuis longtemps et c'est bon ça
c'est bien il faut retravailler sur les
terminaux je pense que sur les terminaux
et sur la transition entre ces terminaux
ferroviaires et le mode routier là il ya
une cartographie de terminaux qu'il faut
reprendre pensée européen vous avez
entièrement raison on peut penser que
franco-français on a de plus en plus
d'entreprises françaises qui ont aussi
des clients en europe or voilà il faut
penser sous ça on voit à peu près ce
qu'il faut faire le très massives au
fond c'est un sujet si le sujet qu'il
faut faire c'est des capillaires le très
massif faut faire attention parce qu'ils
partent du sinn ou de coopératives qui
sont pas tous qui sont souvent très
souvent parfois passionnés du capillaire
faire attention à l'état de céline
capillaire ces salles on veut donc faut
qu'ils aient de l'argent l'an nouveau je
suis désolé de revenir à ces sujets mais
ils sont calmes et fondamentaux il faut
de l'argent pour maintenir les
capillaires nécessaire pour que les
installations terminales embranchées
fonctionne mais côté commercial parce
que là c'est puissant pour remplacer un
train qui fait 40 wagons faut 40 camions
donc là pour le coup le ferroviaire et
compétitif le tout c'est la nécessaire
terminal et les unes capillaire enfin le
wagon isolé il faut vraiment le soutenir
le wagon isolé il a le vent dans le dos
les céréales wagon pour ça qu'on dit
qu'il est isolé
cette terre nancière là le camion est
redoutable cerciat pas d' intervention
du politique le camion il va tout gagner
parce qu'imaginez le camion il part de
l' usine à pour aller au dépôt b
directement le wagon faut la mener avec
un petit look autres acteurs faut qu'ils
se chargent vous revenez le chercher
comme si locotracteur vous l'amener à la
gare de triage vous formez un train il
va être triés une fois ou deux à
l'arrivée à nouveau le kilo contre
acteurs qui l'amène eelv et quatre jours
le camion il a fait quatre fois
l'aller-retour voilà le désavantage
technique venir du magot isolés tels que
c'est pas d'intervention d'une manière
ou d'une autre de la cire public on n'y
arrivera pas mais est ce que veut
fondamentalement c'est justement pas une
impasse c'est à dire de dire c'est pas
sur le wagon isolé qu'il faut mettre
l'effort
et qui ont peut-être le mettre ailleurs
pour développer massivement le fret à
moi je crois pas je crois qu'il faut pas
aller chez les wagons isolés moi je
parce que sinon on va se passer de
beaucoup l'industrie toute l'industrie
n'est pas capable d'envoyer des 30 est
donc là ce cas là on va réduire le champ
de pertinence du ferroviaire si on veut
viser large il faut arriver à traiter
wagon isolé dans son système dead le
gouvernement a accepté pour la première
fois de le faire en france est une
grande première 70 millions d'euros
ayant été mis sur le lait de wagon isolé
les autrichiens par exemple ils ont 32 %
je crois de parts de marché du
ferroviaire
pourquoi il ya plusieurs raisons mais
ils ont un système de mise au lit depuis
très longtemps il n'y a pas de mystère
quand vous êtes aidez vous en sortez
mieux que vous n'êtes pas et les ccc
c'est plus difficile on en revient à
l'enjeu fondamental de permettre toutes
les marchandises sur les camions des
wagons isolés en plus vous avez de la
chimie là dedans vous avez des matières
dangereuses enfin il ya quand même des
natures de marchandises qu'on préfère
voir sur le ferroviaire plutôt que sur
la route voyez donc faut pas lâcher
wagon isolé voilà français et européens
dans l'ordre il faut des systèmes dead
il faut des infrastructures il faut
l'accès au port dans franchement j'ai
voyez je si on a des idées est
d'ailleurs une association qui vendent
la sncf qui s'appelle 4 f qui regroupe
tous les opérateurs de fret ferroviaire
pas que la sncf qui va en force de
proposition qui a fait des propositions
au gouvernement mais voilà on est très
actif là dessus dans désolé ne pas avoir
donné à 7,7 cette image fait de la
corriger nous avons des idées nous
sommes actifs et une faute dans les
propositions ensemble pas que la sncf
bien les cowboys
tac tac tac après j'avais quoi j'avais
la cour des comptes c'est ça gares et
connexions
moi j'ai une lecture pas si négatif que
celle du rapport la cour des comptes
voyez c'est mon côté optimiste moi je
fais du judo m'accorde encore j'ai une
charge je l'apprends j'essaie de
rebondir bon qu'est ce qu'elle dit
fondamentalement elle dit que ça manque
d'argent là aussi au fond qu'est-ce qui
est qu'est-ce que ça dit ce rapport il y
voilà donc à vous manquer d'argent il ya
deux solutions ou il n'y a pas plus
d'argent mais ça va se rétrécir
ou alors il ya plus d'argent elle
renvoie en fait à l'état une fois de
plus la décision si elle va plus
d'argent on va aller vers une forme de
réductions des gares ou de paupérisation
des gars c'est pas terrible comme projet
mais au moins c'est clair c'est cohérent
ne point de vue économique faire
finances publiques accordées quant à ses
carnets quoi sinon si on veut développer
il faut plus d'argent et deuxièmement le
sujet qu'elle soulève celui de
régulation à l'asvel c'est un peu
compliqué on va arriver des badines ici
mais peut-être certains de vous cet
antre vous m'aimez connaissent tout ça
aujourd'hui dans l'est dans l'est dans
l'est dans les règles de régulation de
l'actif tout bien commun les gars ça
appartient aux pays 3000 gares
françaises qui appartiennent à la nation
et qui sont gérées par gares et
connexions sont bien commun la manière
de gérer ce bien commun de réguler pour
l'accès aux autres en fait on voit bien
ce qui a guidé le législateur qui a fait
ces règles c'est que ça coûte le moins
possibles nouveaux entrants ces vertueux
peut-être mais en fait ça a des
conséquences d'abord la rémunération des
investissements est insuffisante aucun
investisseur privé mais très de l'argent
dans les gares parce que le taux de
rémunération qui est fixé par l'autorité
de régulation est très bas il ya un
problème vous ne tirez pas les capitaux
se cale en béton gueule bon ça il faut
pour en parler le moment venu s'il en
aura un problème de financement des
investissements nécessaires à la
rénovation des gares et deuxièmement
vous avez des règles qui sont
avantageuses pour les transporteurs qui
sont les vrais clients d'ecs à l'égard
facture enfin oui font payer les
transporteurs qui les utilisent ya aussi
un phd gare en fait quand gares et
connexions fait deux euros d'économies
elle doit rendre un systématiquement
transporter par la baisse des redevances
c'est pas très motivant quand vous
faites une économie de 100 on vous
oubliez vos en pic 50 il ya un petit
problème voilà donc on pense qu'au tour
des des règles de régulation il faut les
rediscuter abandonné parce qu'elles sont
pas porteuses de comment dire de
ressorts économiques solides voilà donc
voilà les deux sujets de fond moi que je
vois dans ce rapport de la cour des
comptes
et vous redire bourdy a une fois de plus
je suis très clair que la sncf les gares
et connexions souhaite s'occuper de tout
les gars y compris les petites
attentions problématique de
balkanisation d'éclatement etc vous n'y
est pas favorable on pense que ça une
valeur parce que c'est un bien commun de
la france d'avoir une forme d'unité
unités de service unités de voilà qu'on
trouve à peu près les mêmes choses par
catégorie de gare je pense qu'il ya de
la valeur à trouver une forme de deux
d'homogénéité dans les services qu'on
propose dans les gares enfin je vois que
des désaccords qui s'exprime sur cette
affirmation mais c'est le débat c'est le
débat démocratique et je les accepte
bien volontiers
monsieur le président merci un grand
merci
pour avoir
beaucoup de sincérité beaucoup de
volonté
collaborer aux questions qui ont été
posées et pour la qualité de vos
réponses qualité d'eau réponse qui ont
permis de faire le bilan de vos deux
premières années à la tête du du groupe
sncf
nous avons pu le constater et vous
l'avez dit que nos collègues sont très
attachés à leur territoire très attachés
à leur train d' équilibre des
territoires et je crois que c'est une
vraie volonté
et j'en suis heureux chez rue qu'on
puisse effectivement reprendre cette
volonté pour la desserte au mieux de nos
territoires dans tout plein de sujets
sains effectivement là la facilité
d'aller de se rendre sur un lieu de
travail la facilité de se déplacer et
aussi participer à la lutte contre les
gaz à effet de serre je crois que la
sncf un gros travail sur le sujet et
c'est important que nos territoires
soient de mieux en mieux desservis par
des trains des territoires merci
monsieur le président vous partirez pas
simplement vous d'en détecter quelque
chose quand président entrant et
remercie d'abord pour cette audition
j'espère que vous l'avez j'étais un peu
engagés dans mes réponses mais vous avez
sorti la passion que j'ai pour le
ferroviaire en plus je suis quelqu'un
qui ne se pratique pas trop la langue de
bois oui mais elle saura / légitime aux
questions toutes mes questions et sont
toutes légitimes elles pointent tous de
vrais sujets au fond et je peux vous le
dire en conclusion je ne renoncerai
jamais à à la volonté d'avoir un service
de qualité je vais m'engager
personnellement en 2022 je vais
retrouver mon passé de cheminot je vais
refaire du chemin de fer et je vais
passer dans les territoires où ça se
passe mal pour voir pour accélérer les
opérations de remise à niveau voilà donc
on a su le faire dans la région sud est
paca il n'y a pas raison que ça va le
faire en normandie on l'a fait
d'ailleurs une époque ça marchait mieux
en normandie en offrant aux de france on
le fera partout il faut le faire on ne
lâchera pas la qualité de service parce
que c'est la base de la relation entre
les français les scènes cf et vous
faites votre métier quand vous nous le
rappeler donc merci beaucoup mesdames
les sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
pour une autre merci
alors je vais vous faire simplement je
vous fais pas ça n'a pas de là pourtant
je vais vous faire acter parce que ce
matin en réunion de bureau rémy
pointereau nous a dit qu'il abandonnait
la mission qui était la sienne
d'informations sur les perspectives
d'aménagement du territoire être
cohésion territoriale et remplacement de
rim et pointe au jeu vous propose que
nous puissions désigner notre collègue
madame muller brawn s'il n'y a pas
d'opposition pas l'abstention c'est acté
bravo pardon monsieur président juste un
petit mot qui vous concernent aussi pour
les collègues qui sont intéressés par
pure vierge vous ferait qu on est
nombreux à l'être on aura le 18 janvier
la la fédération des industries du
ferroviaire qui doit venir pour un
conseil d'administration au sénat on
vous fera passer une petite invitation
si ça vous intéresse d'y participer très
bien mais c'est alors je vous souhaite à
toutes et à tous de bonnes fêtes de noël
en famille de bonnes fêtes de fin
d'année et puis je vous donne rendez
vous en janvier le 4 janvier
prochain merci bonnes fêtes de fin
d'année
[Musique]